[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
it's Simon Williams birthday today happy
birthday Simon thank you very much
happy birthday to you and
[Music]
it's not only Simon's birthday mine was
Carlson is turning 31 today he will have
the white pieces so let's see if he has
something to celebrate
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and his Challenger are tied after three
games in Dubai 11 games remain to decide
the winner of this world championship
match and David on his birthday will
this be the day that Magnus Crossing
pushes for his first win he'll
definitely hope so it's a big day for
him he's gonna hope he can get a
birthday gift but either way it can
sometimes be difficult to play on your
birthday sometimes if you are a bit
distracted it's uh yeah it's decision
time for Magnus now yeah and he does
also have some bad memories against
karyakin in 2016 of pushing too hard
with the white pieces and losing
um to kariakin with the black pieces
then is will that be in the back of his
head possibly it's always traumatizing
when you lose with the white pieces and
at this level if you press too hard if
you're attacked too soon it can backfire
so Magnus he'll try and get a position
where there isn't too much risk involved
where he can put some pressure on the
cornichi and it was also on this day
exactly five years ago that Magnus cross
lifted the trophy against Sergey
kayaking defending his title now you
started out saying 70 30 in favor of
Magnus Carlsen against what you say now
David uh it's difficult uh it's
difficult to weigh up those odds I'm
still going to stick to 70 30 because I
think Magnus would be too unhappy three
draws yes but he does have more white
pieces remaining now than black pieces
in the remainder of the tournament so
I'm still going to say Magnus Carlsen
he's gonna hope that uh he can grind
down the pony actually eventually all
right well game three two days ago it
was a quite Quick Draw but it was not
without mystery in the opening phase
on the third day of the fide World
Championship in Dubai Titans Carlson and
apomniacci locked horns in a calculated
encounter Magnus Johnson has laid his
Pawn to E5 that means he's in
preparation and is following some
fantastic calculations that he's
probably made with his team are you
saying you're getting ruined for Magnus
Carlsen now I think he should be fine
but he's got to be at
energetic normally when you have a bad
Pawn structure for example in the
situation that's now about to arise on
the board after Queen takes Queen sorry
um okay he has taken with the Rook so we
will reach this position when you have a
bad Pawn structure as black you have to
be energetic it's a good strategy there
I mean a draw will happen but good
strategy for Magnus Carlton he's got a
light Square Bishop so he puts his pawns
on dark squares that's just something
for everyone at home not every Bush pen
game is drawn this one happens to be and
it's about to be a draw let's go back to
the players it's a move 42 David it's a
draw in game three between my news
Carlson yeah I wasn't thrilled to have
this ending but I felt that
it was generally well within the drying
range and yeah I was happy to live with
it of course to this pure Bishop's
ending because I get to centralize the
king and push the pawn and create a
barrier
we are ready in the studio to now follow
game four from do I also joined today by
Grandmaster aryantari the second
strongest Grandmaster in Norway also a
friend of Magnus and Aryan what do you
think about the match so far
so far it's been a lot of interesting
games uh fighting for sure
um and uh today Magnus has the white
pieces playing on his birthday I think
he's going to play very aggressive and
uh try to put put as much pressure as
possible yeah we have to
happened before the rest of Ivanka so
you are following the online data base
during that game and you discovered
something intriguing in the start of the
game yeah it was very mysterious and
first of all the line had been analyzed
before on these Cloud engines had been
analyzed in October and it also had been
analyzed two days before that so this
was game one we were thinking you know
this line is pretty obscure what are the
chances that this is just by accident so
we're thinking it could have been
someone from magnus's team who was just
double checking the Lions and uh I don't
know that would be a serious leak
actually we did confront the players
with this discovery after the game this
year the reaction to it
I am a owner from the global broadcasts
of Chess 24 the question is primarily
for Magnus and would also love to hear
if Ian had a reaction it appears that
today's game was analyzed in an online
database all the way up until move 20.
two days ago uh if this was somebody
from your team who forgot to make it
private how would you react
okay
uh I I don't think
um
yeah I don't think anyone any of us can
reasonably uh comment on that
well I I I can only say that normally
you try to switch up this uh online
Cloud uh uh option in in US basement you
analyze you have to make sure no one
uses and no one uses let's say uh your
fruitful analysis but I mean uh
it could probably be a coincidence as
well
so David why is it such a big blunder if
someone from the teams have forgot to
make this analyzed of it well nowadays
the margins are so small at the top
level everyone is so good that it's all
about information it's all about these
small margins and uh if you do know that
someone has studied a certain position
in the opening you're looking at and if
it was recent it's quite likely to be
your opponent's team and
um just having that kind of sense of
direction finding out what your
opponents might be looking at that I
think that's the key I mean if for
example Napoleon actually had been able
to predict to move 20 he would have been
able to go even further still using top
computers and uh he would have gained a
big Advantage having that having that
knowledge so yeah it's uh nowadays you
just need to hide everything you see how
secretive the players are about their
teams about their coaches
and I think there'll be some serious
words within the camps yeah after that
after that and Aaron I know you've been
working as a second for Anish Gary is it
actually possible to forget to turn off
private mode when you are working on
some opening preparations yeah it can
actually happen sometimes because
usually it can turn on automatically and
then you forget to turn it off uh it has
it has happened but it's very important
that let's say you analyze a position
which hasn't happened so many times
before it's like a new line then it's so
important to turn it off because uh
you're like discovering some new things
and you don't want other people to to
find it
all right well maybe there was some
cleaning up on the rest day yesterday in
the Magnus Orion's team but Magnus on
the rest day he also played football of
course and you're like how welcome do
you think this rest day was for the two
players I I think it was very welcome I
mean playing three games in a row it's
quite exhausting and also we have to
mention that in 2018 and 2016 well 2018
at least the players just played two
games and then took a rest day so here
it would have been three games and as
you can see Magnus very much enjoying
himself and relaxing in the way he does
best which is by playing sports do we
know anything about what yarn did or can
we what do you think John did on the
rest day David we can only speculate
unfortunately Jan is quite private he
has been throughout the last few months
and uh knowing him probably just a bit
of Chess a bit of relaxation just trying
to stay in the same routine I'm not sure
he would have been doing the same things
I doubt there would be a football fan
his mind is usually very good on the day
after rest days Ariana because he is
very good at relaxing and doing other
stuff I haven't looked at the statistics
but I would think so yeah he usually
really enjoys doing some some sports on
the rest and then he gets energy for the
for the next day yeah uh yeah I think
it's a very nice frame to relax
definitely yeah traditionally Magnus
sees maybe a bit of a slow starter it
takes him a game or two to get into the
flow but now it's been three games he's
had that rest day I wouldn't be
surprised if I uh like Aaron says if he
does find that energy now and start
accelerating yep and we definitely want
energy from social media today as always
Ivanka yeah yeah the match so far has
been absolutely incredible and we want
you at home to be very much involved in
this experience so we're asking us we're
asking you to show us your selfies where
are you watching the match from who are
you watching the match with we Oscar
also asking for your thoughts your moves
suggestions and we would definitely
feature them on the show so you can
tweet Us by using the hashtag c24 live
definitely go ahead and tweet us
everyone we're gonna head down to Dubai
now we have two teams on ground in Dubai
one of them is Tanya she's in the
playing venue close to the players but
also close to some legendary chess
players
we're at the Dubai Exhibition Center and
the match game four Starts Now now this
is a new stage in the match because the
first three games were all about the
unnerving tension settling down into
math so this means we're going to see
new strategies new gameplay and as the
players take their seats on their right
side the auditorium's there on our left
side we've got another icon another
Legend who's here for fide as part of
their commentary team I've got with me
five times world champion vishwanathan
thank you for joining us
Anand we are back here after the rest
day three games down what adjustments
are you expecting the teams have made
well this is uh only two games now
before the next rest day so I guess
um just tweak whatever they're going to
do
um probably the responsibility falls on
nepo to come up with something more with
white than in the third game
um which means that Magnus probably had
a chance to spend more time on white he
also managed to watch a lot of football
and basketball so hopefully he's relaxed
as well
and it's also his birthday what's it
like to play on on your birthday
I think you yourself don't care but it's
a distraction if everyone else starts
mentioning it at least that was my
experience
and speaking of your immense experience
touches
well the the night before the rest day
was obviously my favorite because that's
when you can switch out the computers
you you let go and it's a day when the
whole team was given off next day you
put it off as long as possible I would
put it off till at least noon or at
least lunch and then the inevitable you
have to start working again
um that was my usual routine so it's
just a chance to break from the routine
because as long as the games are going
on you're never quite are able to rest
so it's it's nice to have this rest day
break yeah I was
I was out resting
of course after three games you want to
relax a bit but also the tension of the
upcoming round is building up yes very
much like I said the night before and
the half the rest day you can actually
rest and disconnect and then reality
strikes I mean your team has probably
started working a bit and then when you
go to the room they say well there's a
to-do list it's growing and well then
you have to just sit down and get
through that
so far has been sort of different from
his usual style of play he's been very
much in control consistent uh has kept a
solid approach quite unlike what a lot
of us were expecting from speed
dangerous and the fast Yan that we've
come to know and his unpredictability
what kind of a Challenger is he proving
to be
well that's to be expected and it's
still very early stages it's three games
in a 14-game match so these traits could
come out still but for the moment
I think especially in game two you saw
some impulsiveness of the players it's
only very late in the game that the
impulsive stuff starts so Magnus
plundered The Exchange then he decided
to
uh play for Bishop E4 Ian panicked a bit
uh panicked at the thought of this
bishop at seven fourth rank transfer so
he tried to anticipate that with C3
which is a very very complicated
solution a very very complicated to an
answer to a question which wasn't being
posed
so that's really the only moment of
impulsiveness everything else looks like
there's ticking script but these moments
eventually come out I mean there's uh
most games will be decided in one or two
moments and they're they're starting to
come so
um I think for the moment it's the match
we wanted
the legendary uh Vision on the previous
world champion thinking about the game
coming today we of course have the
prediction challenge going on guys the
Magnus nepo prediction challenge you are
doing quite well David Howell what have
you predicted for today yeah so far so
good for me but today is actually the
first time I'm really unsure what
opening it will be Magnus could take a
variety of approaches I've seen I've
said it's going to be a Queen's Gambit
but it could be anything really and uh
I've said a Magnus win in 42 moves what
about you yamaka well I've been
predicting decisive results and I've
clearly failed there so this time I'm
gonna go for a draw and also like David
I've also gone for a queen's gamble I do
think that Magnus is gonna repeat what
he played in game two all right well
Ariana's told me that he has not signed
up for the prediction challenge yet so
we're gonna have a commercial break now
and that's a good time for all of you at
home as well to submit your prediction
on magnusnepo.com we'll be back after a
quick commercial break
[Applause]
today more than ever when the world
comes together to create a better
tomorrow it's going to be the largest
[Music]
magic magic
with music with architecture with colors
magic with celebration with your safety
From Here There and Everywhere for six
hormones day and night join the making
of a new world starting October 1st
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the new chess 24 playing
experience play in light mode or dark
mode choose from a range of time
controls or create a custom game and get
paired with players from around the
world fast enjoy a polished playing
experience while making moves on a fresh
responsive board to claim your victories
train and improve with over 80 000
puzzles and that's not all download now
and discover what more you can enjoy in
our brand new app
this is John John loves to study chess
[Music]
this is David David loves to study chess
as well but efficiently
John spends more time setting up the
board and figuring out what's on the
page of his folks then he gets to study
David likes to take it easy
and use his time wisely
[Music]
David has finished his exercise for
today
done to try the same
[Music]
now anyone can learn and improve their
chess skills with the world champion
Magnus Carlson
the Magnus trainer app is packed with
fun mini games in interactive training
content playable anytime anywhere get
the Magnus trainer available in the App
Store and Google Play
foreign
Global we are looking forward to game
four in the world championship match and
this is world champion Magnus Carlsen
arriving as always staying inside the
car with his trainer Peter heiner for up
to 10 minutes probably discussing the
upcoming game it is Magnus carlsen's
birthday today turning 31 years old it's
also Simon William's birthday today and
Simon first of all happy birthday thank
you cheers yeah so what is it like to
play chess and such an important game as
well on your birthday
I'm I mean I suppose it's a bit daunting
sometimes
um I think Anan said a very good thing
there that you know if people mention
mention it's your birthday then you're
going to get a bit like flustered Maybe
by that thought and we can see here uh
Magnus getting out of the car quite
early there
um I think it's also steinert's the
first world champion who said you should
never play chess on your birthday really
yeah I think he said that so just
because any distraction at all can maybe
take you away from the focus but my
thinking with this this game
particularly is that Magnus has been
rested he's in a good mood he's got the
white pieces he's got the first games
out of the way and he is a bit shaky
sometimes at the starter tournaments the
start of these things so I think he's
going to be in a very good mood to uh to
to play very interesting game today so
I'm excited very excited but there is an
interesting stat because there has not
been played 17 classical world
championship match games in a row that
has ended with draws the two last ones
in the creaking match in 2016. all of
the games against Corona in 2018 and now
the three first games in this one now
playing all of these draw games is that
a legacy that Magnus Crossing is just
dying to get rid of
yeah I think it's certainly a legacy
you'd like to get rid of as long as it
wins he probably doesn't want to lose a
game to to get rid of that Legacy but um
it's so tough at this level and I I know
there was even some criticism about the
the 12 draws in the last World
Championships but I view it totally
differently I think the tension is so
fine little mistakes little margins make
all the difference so it's uh it's a
tough game and you can just see the
tension on the board and that's kind of
what makes it interesting but I honestly
think he's got a great chance today
because with the white pieces the rest
this is a good chance yep and it is his
birthday maybe a day to celebrate he is
turning 31 years old today Magnus
Carlsen was born on this day in 1990 now
his father tried to teach him chess when
he was four and a half years old but uh
Magnus calls me he wasn't a Chess Union
from the very gecko
they're still our kids a little a couple
of them are reached 30 already
so Magnus grew up
in the in the 90s
quite the cute cute boy
Magnus was born in November 1990
he already had a
sister L who was one and a half years
old
we would trade off uh me playing with
more girly things and getting him to
join playing with dolls and doing a
dress up and do songs and be all showy
and then I would have to play with his
cars and you know he loved reading about
the commune flags and knowing the area
of all the communes and the number of
inhabitants and he would make me quiz
him and the favorite one is John Deere
ah so like any other kid yeah
yeah my wife and I we considered our
children to be absolutely normal
basically
teacher
they had some special traits
and clearly Magnus he was into
concentrating for hours at the time
doing various tasks
whether it was Legos or chess or math or
sports results and this is from his Lego
face
he turned five and he was yeah it was
fun to have some friends over but I
think his main occupation was a new big
Lego he had received that day do any
chest pictures in here or is this too
early this is too early
[Music]
Magnus had shown a clear inclination and
ability to certain activities
concentrates activities that I thought
would match well with chess basically so
I tried to teach Magnus and his older
sister chess when he was four and a half
and then it was so difficult for them
really I mean they could learn the rules
we could play some games
typically I would start with just one
Pawn on my king and they would try to
beat me with all their forces but in the
end it was usually a stalemate or even
or sometimes I even won with my one Pawn
if I had any
aspirations for the kids basically that
that went all the way during the first
year or two
fortunately because it turned out that
chess was much more difficult than I had
understood basically and when Magnus
started becoming really interested in
Chess at seven and a half he said
because he wanted to beat his older
sister
then I didn't have that much ambition on
his behalf and he was allowed to develop
and flourish on his own basically
and then maybe a year half a year later
I rediscovered that okay he has a talent
for chess my initial inclination was
right
that was a memorable trip
when he was eight and a half he played
his first tournament and before that he
practiced
the notation so then he wanted to play
one game against me when we were at our
cabin up in the mountains and I agreed
after some pressure from him and Dad and
that was the first time he beat me
and he was eight and a half that was his
first tournament overall basically and I
thought he would do quite well because
he had learned so much during the those
six seven months but playing a
tournament was somewhat different so he
came 11th I think in the end or 13th and
he liked it a lot and then the year a
year later he won this group here his
grandfather joined him to Iceland that
was one of his first
kind of important victories and we jump
the Vic hammer
later to become his second yeah
I think he was second there as well so I
have to become Grandma this year
and is that realistic yes I think quite
realistic
[Music]
chess was very much his life from from
the age of eight
foreign
happy birthday even though it's coming
from Moscow and we're voting for Yan but
we wish you all the best you're the best
player cheers yeah happy birthday Magnus
from Canada well happy Birthday World
Champion
um cheers from all of the fans in India
I wish him happy birthday and that I'd
like to be I like the way he plays do
you have a message from Magnus on his
birthday
uh yes uh Magnus I'm a great fan of you
and I'm Danish so I'm going to say it in
Danish
happy birthday Magnus yes happy birthday
and keep us dreaming we try stay please
thank you happy birthday Magnuson I'll
be continuing to play great games um in
the rest of the tournament all about my
favorite is Nepal but happy birthday
nonetheless
all the best for your birthday enjoy
your day and I hope that that bleeds
through to your chest and you play some
of your best yes happy birthday Magnus
have a great match to be full
concentrate on the match and hope to see
the great moves
happy birthday and the best wishes and
of course good health and good result
and much we are fond of you and I am I'm
impressed with with your game magdus
happy birthday I know you'll be 31 years
old and I know you're going to win this
tournament soon so blessings and I love
you
and happy birthday to you Magnus Carlsen
from us here in the global broadcast as
well of course and I am being Norwegian
a Norwegian Grandmaster what has Magnus
match for Norwegian chess
uh for Norwegian chess it's uh it meant
so much because from 2013 they started
to send chess on TV and then it became
like so much more popular I was just
like 14 years old at the time and I
really felt it when I went to school
that everybody started talking about it
and uh it just felt like chess was so
much more respected and it was a really
nice feeling to be a be a part of that
yeah
yeah so Norway like feels like a chess
Nation now thanks to him exactly we do
see the playing venue we are waiting for
young and Magnus Carlsen to arrive for
game four and uh do you think Ariana
that you would have been where you are
today without Magnus Carlsen is it
possible to sort of
think back would it be possible to to
you know go for a chess career that's a
that's a good question uh
I mean I think I would be definitely at
a lower rated lower level if it was not
for for minus because I got like more
opportunities because of him and just
being more popular uh yeah so
big thanks to him
yep my name is Carlson will it be a
victory for him on his birthday with the
white pieces uh David you what did you
say in the prediction challenge you said
I said that Magnus would win yeah I said
it would be a Queen's Gambit and it
would be 42 moves but uh we've seen lots
of long games so far
where's the black pieces
from Russia the Challenger
Maurice actually introducing the players
Magnus Carlsen is ready although again
with a white suit so that seems to be uh
what he's gonna do for this world
championship match dress in the colors
that he is playing with
and that is Maurice Ashley working for
Fida who is also introducing at
workwitch let's see if there's going to
be a celebrity making the first move
here today I realized in game three
there was a famous tennis player we
didn't see that which way but yeah she's
number she's quite high top 10 in the
world at least so yeah I haven't studied
my tennis too well I guess for my top 10
I think yeah former tennis player yeah
all right it's gonna be interesting to
see that and if a celebrity pops up here
to make the first move for Magnus
Carlsen so far none of them has made the
right first move correct not yet oh okay
well okay people and push forward
how shocked will everyone in that room
be if Magnus does not push that pawn
back
I'm not sure he played this against you
at the World Cup
he played against me but usually you
don't see it in the world championship
match usually it's like D4 and E4 are
the main moves but uh we'll see in a
second I guess okay the move has been
taken back What's it gonna be is that a
King's Pawn D4 I think that's E4 oh
that's E4 oh well all of our predictions
are wrong with the opening unfortunately
wow it's a king spawn opening and how
will Napoleon actually react big moment
it's E5 no Sicilian okay so they're like
switching the colors because minus with
black against Dion it was E4 E5 so now
now we see minus uh playing it Forward
right it's always uh nice to see new new
openings being played so this is so far
the same as in game three uh yeah until
this last move uh janaponics she now has
just played copycat and it's the Petrov
defense I wonder how many people would
have guessed this because uh yeah
Napoleon actually not known for this
opening uh he played it a couple of
times I think in the candidates
tournament earlier this year but that
was really the first time we've seen it
from him and uh it's not traditionally
his style either just to play kind of a
drawish uh kind of solid opening and
okay Magnus is going to pull up
temporarily
but White's night having grabbed
opponent gets kicked back and the pony
actually will regain his Pawn so this is
well known stuff and I remember this
this happened a lot right in the match
between castle and Carolina in 2018.
yeah this is uh the Petrov and it's
known to be like the most solid openings
uh in chess but but as uh David said
it's a bit surprising that yam plays it
because he it's not usually his style he
plays like he played like Sicilian his
whole life he's known to be an
aggressive player but uh for the match
it's uh probably a good strategy it's
interesting I was talking to Anish like
two months ago and we were discussing
which opening Jan will go for after E4
and I was thinking the Sicilian but
Anish actually predicted that Jan will
go for the Petrov uh and I was surprised
that he he said that but he was actually
actually right spots on yeah Anish giri
clearly uh yeah you can see the future
so uh meanwhile a couple more moves
both sides just occupying the sense with
pawns bringing Bishops out this is still
very very standard stuff and uh okay I
wonder who will launched the first
surprise because I think Magnus avoided
this exact position uh in his match
against Carolina he was trying different
lines or against the Petrov as white
okay both sides now just castling their
kings
still very traditional very well-known
territory here and Yan we've seen this
actually
normally when it's his move like when
it's Magnus move sorry he just doesn't
State the wood yeah actually during this
match has been not staying so much at
the board he likes to I don't know go to
the restroom or just stay in the chill
children maybe he feels the pressure or
something but this is a very topical
line these days it's been played in some
top games I've been looking at this line
quite quite recently actually it's uh
White usually goes C4 here
it's a very logical move for putting
upon
and attacking the center with with C4
and that pawn cannot really be taken
because it's defending the the Knight
so I think that's what minus is gonna do
so it's sort of a trending opening then
yeah very very trendy and uh seen many
games recently yeah other moves might
include just bring the Rook okay he does
go for your uh your suggestion though
this is the most popular reply but you
mentioned it's trendy as well it kind of
goes through phases right the Petrov
um a few years back it was really
popular with kramnik and girl fan
defending the black pieces and then
people stopped playing it they went to
the Berlin but now after Carolina
started playing it now everyone's back
at the petrol so it's like with fashion
It's Fashion yeah openings they're all
about fashion wow these days Berlin
Queen's Gambit they're still in fashion
but Petrov maybe uh
yeah it's it's experiences those Trends
quite a lot and seeing it now in the
world championship match that's probably
going to boost the popularity even more
yeah yeah a pet shop has been very
popular for many years but it's been
like on and off it goes through stages
but uh being being played at a world
championship it means that you checked
it so much so exactly yeah so might be
that people will play it even more now
usually a black plays uh Pawn to C6 to
support his his Center because uh his
Pawn is under attack now
so we'll we'll see I think when the
island comes back he's gonna do that
pretty fast yeah both players for sure
would have predicted this position
um it might have come as a small
surprise to Magnus the Petrov but he
will have seen Jan played it and he will
have some idea up his sleep at least I
was gonna one thing I've noticed about
this match is that Magnus has been very
keen to launch a surprise to which
Napoleonic has known a little bit but
Magnus is known one move further where
do you think the surprise will come
that's uh that's a good question because
minus had to see Petrov coming as as
David pointed out he played it in the
candidates so it was it was possible
we'll uh we'll see after after C6
I yeah it's hard to say I'm really
curious about it one interesting point
to uh to say is that in the last game in
Norway chess when Magnus played E4
against the only young actually played
the Berlin defense I think it was kind
of a psychological game he was doing
there pretending that he's going to play
Berlin in the in the match but then
keeping having Petrov instead so I think
he was kind of Faking It with playing
the burden in Norway chess all right
take it until you make it yeah it's all
about those false Trails those kind of
Mind Games yeah yeah because then
magnus's team will have to have studied
a lot the Berlin have some ideas in that
yeah especially the Berlin that will
take weeks to study just to come up with
a few ideas so um I wonder how much time
Magnus and his coaches devoted to this
opening and there we go uh Aryan is
correct black does bolster his Pawn
center with the move C6 and Matthew one
yeah brings this Rook across all right
well every day we have accessible
opening course free for everyone at home
and since it's magnus's birthday today's
opening course is a strategy lesson with
the world champion himself Magnus
Carlson so you can go check that out on
the link below it is a free course so go
check it out on chessball and study it
while you're watching this game unfold
because then you can definitely learn
something and it is
in the movie is he at the board right
now
yeah because usually he plays so fast so
you would kind of okay he's actually
yeah rookie one is I think it's this
maybe a second main move uh usually
recently I've seen white player Knight
C3 mostly but rookie one is also very
logical uh putting the Rook on a better
square and pressing against the E4
Knight yeah and actually maybe we can
show this because this is magnus's
strategy Ivanka mentioned earlier often
he'll play a Mainline opening but then
he'll only choose the third or fourth
fourth most popular move and this one is
the most trendy bring the white knight
out putting some pressure on the center
and uh I know historically as well they
used to take on this Square first and
then bring the white knight out and this
is I mean this leads to a lot of uh
opening Theory a lot of well-known lines
uh personally in this position as well
uh I've played this move against
Vladimir kramnik this is going back oh
God I'm old uh more than 10 years ago
but either way rookie one um it's also
very logical putting some pressure on
the center now
I'm just trying to remember what the
main moves are I can I can help you out
there so the main moves today are
actually to develop the light Square
Bishop to reinforce the Knight and move
the bishop to F5 uh another move is to
support the to develop the bishop one
square further actually just to move it
to G4 you know pin and win and then
another popular move is to develop the
rook and to reinforce the Knight and if
black is feeling really really energetic
you can also support the Knight with a
pawn that's been played a handful of
times
and uh yeah this one looks very nice
because you cement your night in the
center but you do also give away control
over some squares and uh later on black
might have to deal with a knight jumping
into the center and that's now an
outpost for white so I would be
surprised to be honest if we see this
Pawn push
Jan just taking some time to mull over
the options okay he's looking off to the
left there that means he's just
recalling something rather than actually
trying to calculate anything new but uh
once he does spend a couple of minutes
I'm I'm pretty sure he'll bring out this
bishop I'm not sure where yeah I think
he's going to go with the bishop to F5
it looks
very logical just develop the bishop and
protect the knights but I'm uh I'm quite
surprised Dion is thinking for like two
minutes now three minutes yeah because
uh this is one of the critical lines but
but he's I guess he's just trying to
remember maybe he looked at more options
here and he's trying to choose which one
to go for yeah I mean they're all quite
similar in this type of position this
move bringing the Rook across there's a
few options for white so maybe he's just
trying to recall it's uh still very
standard position
he is thinking now for three minutes
let's uh head down to Dubai to get the
latest from outside the arena
it's a great day for chess everybody
again the white weather is awesome the
sky is blue and I am here at the Spanish
Pavilion with wfm Ashlyn Martinez am I
saying that right yes w-i-m ah sorry
sorry the f is not there W I am even
better even better and you are here as a
chess professional Fortress 24 but
you're also here as a chess fan tell me
actually what is it like to be in what I
feel is chess Heaven wow this is amazing
it's like the paradise for any chess
player I think we have here the Spanish
Pavilion full of Chess but also if you
go to the playing Hall the Chesney for
lounge you just like a smell chest
everywhere do you have time to follow
the game and do you think we have any
prediction for what will happen today
well kinda I followed I'm bad because
actually we have so many activities here
during the games but yeah it's going to
be super exciting today is Mango's
birthday so for sure like they will have
some action as usual
well thank you very much Ashlyn and
congratulations to Magnus on his
birthday of course guys back to you
ah thanks for that report ruin it looks
so warm and nice in Dubai you guys are
so lucky now we had two moves in the
game yep a couple of moves so first of
all Yan did protect his Knight in the
center by bringing the black light
Square Bishop out as Aryan predicted and
now a very quick reply from Magnus
Carlsen showing that he's well prepared
bringing out the White Queen and
um every move has consequences right
that's something that Ivanka always
reminds me and uh this White Queen now
is targeting upon on the B7 square that
is no longer protected by Black's light
squared Bishop yeah you're smiling I'm
smiling at you because guess what Magnus
hasn't hasn't chosen the most popular
move which actually would be the line
that you indicated with the queen moving
to the C2 Square it is the second most
popular move which is actually to
develop the queen to the B3 square like
David says uh highlighting the
consequences now I'm smiling because
this appears to be magnus's like
strategy to pick those openings those
those Sidelines within the main lines
that maybe napoleoni hasn't studied
um that's why I just love the Intrigue
what can I say and he's Napoleon
actually has responded very quickly
again and this is also not the most
popular response uh he's just developed
his Queen one square protecting the pawn
that was Under Fire the most popular
move was just to ignore it and actually
develop the Knight to the edge of the
board but look at the bar here it's gone
up to 1.3 for minus Crossing what do you
think about this move David yeah um I'm
just trying to work out because the end
upon actually he spent around eight
minutes now on the clock and just before
he played this queen move as black I saw
him on the camera smiling is this
because he kind of knows what's going on
or is it because he's already maybe
caught off guard and he's kind of half
bluffing it's not clear to me sometimes
I've faced upon actually many uh on many
occasions and sometimes he might be out
of book but then he'll continue playing
fast just to try and scare his opponent
and
yeah a very logical move just defending
everything with the black queen but then
again
at the evaluation bar not so happy maybe
white does have an idea or two here to
put some pressure on Ivanka what's
what's been played here before so what's
been played here before um the most
recent game I have here on the database
is actually a game between Lavon aronian
and Arjun erikaisi one of the
competitors on the mount water Champions
chess tour only 16. and there Levant
played in a very committed way he pushed
his Pawn forward uh Magnus has gone for
a little bit more flexible move and
develops tonight again this is the most
popular move I wonder whether napometri
smiled because they had maybe predicted
how Magnus would react more possibly we
can maybe figure that out because okay
we do have another move a quick one from
Jana pognacci trade of knights now there
will be some exchanges I think white is
about to capture the Bishops okay the
Bishops are about to come off the board
and then I think Magnus will just
recatch the Knight and continue pulling
pressure with his queen against some
weak Pawns all right well let's head
down to Dubai because Tanya is right now
standing with Vladimir Putin the trainer
of Vienna pomijachi who can maybe answer
if they're happy now with what what's
happening in the opening stage here
well that's the big question guy and of
course one E4 by Magnus was a slight
surprise at least up in the play Magnus
group room a wedding Magnus is because I
think Catalan was what everyone was
expecting a little more testing but the
battle of the openings continue and for
more insights we've got with us
long time trainer a Grandmaster
top-level Grandmaster himself the former
European Champion uh Vladimir botkin
with us thank you for joining us
Vladimir of course one E4 was that
expected or were you thinking it's going
to be another Catalan well Magnus is
very flexible player he can start to use
any pawn and
today he has birthday maybe he's on some
special mood so batyan is ready to fight
and of course it will be a good game
now if you have to play Magnus you have
to expect one E4 it can't be that big a
surprise yeah that's for sure all right
and yesterday was the rest day tell us a
little bit about that what was it like
for team napamiyachi how did you guys
spend the rest there well rest day is
always good and also we had an
opportunity to try to Russian Cuisine
maybe you know some Olivia and borch
Russian deals and of course it's always
nice to have some Spirit from your
native country to fill in Dubai
and uh the position that we do have
right now out of the Russian defense uh
do you think Jan is comfortable in this
position the outcome of the opening
well certainly if there is a Russian
defense it can be expected from Russian
player yeah but let's see so it will be
some good battle I think some fighting
position and the
first rounds shows that they are ready
to fight and this game will not be an
exception and we've seen that we've seen
that in the first three games also both
players ready to fight the one thing
that all of us have been noticing
Vladimir is this slightly different Yan
that we've been talking about you know
he's so much more in control so much
more confident uh a lot consistent with
his move having a solid approach we were
expecting a very aggressive
unpredictable yarn that we are used to
that's a is that something that the team
has worked on
well I think Giannis improving last year
as certainly and he is doing great job
and even for me as a coach I am like
expecting what to see from Beyonce's
next game and I'm inspired to see him
like playing good feeling good and uh
feeling comfortable in such a big match
for him
to what they've witnessed in the in the
three games how involved was Jan himself
in this in match progression of training
well it's every player has his own
recipe and it's always flexible or when
you feel inspiration you are involved
it's definitely
doesn't create world championship match
between these two thank you so much
Vladimir
purely doing all the right things that's
required to give us a big fight at the
world championship match
ah definitely thank you so much Tanya
for giving us insight to team nepo we do
have a couple of moves what do you think
David we do have a couple of moves and
Magnus is continuing to Blitz continuing
to play fast and just this last queen
move by white
again that reeks to me of computer
preparation that's maybe not the most
human move normally we would be looking
to push pawns or develop pieces but
Magnus moving a queen for the second
time
I'm trying to figure out the idea but
clearly there is one behind that and
Napoleon actually also reacting
instantly both players clearly within
that preparation yeah
um definitely as David says uh the
computers have really changed the nature
of the game but surprisingly enough this
position has been played before Maxine
vashilograph against Fabiano caruana as
another 10 games in my database as well
the oldest one being Michael Adams
against Alexander morosevic
still the same with that Queen Retreat
um and incidentally I have to say that
Maxim vashilograph was the last well was
one of the players to play it this
variation but I do know that he landed
in Dubai he probably just to watch the
match but I I love the fact that none of
the teams have announced that a second
so we can speculate and have fun I think
he's doing maybe some commentary for the
French 24 or he's just relaxing there
who knows yeah yeah but now uh Magnus
played a different move than Maxime
played in that game I think he paid Rook
to be one that's right yeah so now
Magnus plays a pawn to A4 I think that's
a good move supporting the supporting
the queen and if black now uh takes on
B5
uh White can take with the pawn and then
uh I think the opponent B5 is doing a
great job because as David is pointing
out the a file uh becomes very nice for
The Rook on A1 and the Poland A7 becomes
pretty weak will we definitely lose the
Queens quite soon it's quite likely
um actually it's just happened I think
black has taken the Queens um just
before we show this as well some of the
viewers at home might have been
wondering in this position why okay
instead of white defending the queen why
why can't uh couldn't have grabbed a
pawn uh this would have been a huge
blunder unfortunately so white takes a
pawn but because of the tension between
the Queen's black would have been able
to play Bishop takes porn check giving
away the bishop but gaining time and
then after white recaptures the White
Queen would have dropped off so we did
indeed see a trade of Queens instead of
this Magnus defending his Queen the
Queen's parting from the board and
immediately yeah Napoleon actually
pushes forward and wow yeah Magnus
reacts again instantly so Magnus here he
did have the opportunity to take this
Pawn as if it just moved one square he
could have played on passant he could
have captured but black then would have
been able to trade off even more pieces
and maybe white has a small Advantage
because black has two isolated pawns but
with limited material with so many
exchanges probably it will fizzle out
towards the draw so uh Magnus instead of
playing on passant which is super
tempting
he's just ignored it and brought his
Knight to the edge of the board so he's
given black a protective passport long
term this is going to be a very nice
kind of trump card for black to use in
the end game but he's trying to get in
with the white knight to a nice square
that looks like a very interesting move
uh if if the white knight gets to F5
it's pretty annoying there let's say if
black were to develop his Knight now
which looks logical to D7 then white can
play a knight to F5
and the bishop doesn't really have any
good squares to go to has to go to C7
and then this is pretty annoying because
white can just give a check on E7 with
the Knights the King has to move and
then take the pawn so Jan has to be
careful about the Knight coming to F5
maybe G6 looks uh sensible normally you
never want to allow or not into F5 in
any middle game right uh or any end game
so G6 stopping this uh Knight jumping in
but this gives away some squares too
with a white Bishop jump in now do you
think or yeah Bishop to H6 maybe two I'd
like to rook and then maybe Rook C8
yeah I'm curious what minus has in mind
but I think G6 uh has to be played to
stop Knight F5 as far as I can see yeah
so this move
I mean it's first instinct right just so
natural because what else
but the consequences will be that white
jumps in with the bishop gains a bit of
time and
try to find the follow-up this Knight is
a bit offside now that's the one
downside for Magnus but if you can
reroute it later on um if you can for
example gain time and maybe reroute this
Knight towards the center then maybe he
can go for Black's isolated Pawn
in the middle of the board but then
again with both Kings on that side
wouldn't it be nice to have some pieces
on that side as well possibly although
now the Queens are off it's unlikely
there'll be any checkmates as long as
both sides keep control over their back
rank for example here black shouldn't
get greedy and capture a pawn with his
Rook because the white Rook would
actually trap the black king this will
end in Checkmate so as long as you keep
control of your back rank for both sides
the Kings should be relatively safe so
does that mean in a game like this the
big aim is to promote a pawn to a queen
eventually so it's going to be at some
point maybe a pawn race if we get that
far yeah and also targeting weaknesses
and in this position I think black's
main weakness is this guy
um it's isolated and if you can somehow
reroute your knight to attack it you'll
be doing great with white but then again
black if black can maybe attack this
Pawn a backward Pawn later on then black
has some chances too so
definitely in the balance right now but
both sides have something to hope for
feels like a very different game from
game three because we already lost a
bunch of pieces on the board Magnus has
played Super quickly yeah GE definitely
has taken some pulses and the plans seem
to be pretty clear-cut as David kind of
highlighted you know why it has a Target
to attack the weak Pawn in the center
black is banking all their hopes on
actually this protective passport which
is the best type of Pawn there is on the
board and uh so I mean both sides
definitely will be wanting to put their
pieces on their natural squares and in
that sense it is completely different to
games one and two which were kind of
murky very unclear positions neither
side knew entirely what they were doing
are you guys slightly surprised that the
evaluation bar has gone over to
blackside here I mean yeah he just says
0.8 for black that can't it can't be
accurate I think because minus is
clearly still in preparation he has
played fast so I think he the computer
he has looked with must be deeper than
this one yeah I mean we're using
stockfish here which is a very strong
engine but probably they've been using
stop fish on uh higher processors and uh
maybe they've been looking with Leela
zero with the neural network engine
which often gives different evaluations
so this one Let's ignore the evaluation
buffer now uh I reckon it's still in the
balance with best play it's going to be
interesting how much time Jan is going
to spend here because it plays a very
big role who starts to think first uh
like who is better prepared so let's say
if Jan would uh would spend like 10
minutes here or 20 minutes that would be
kind of uh opening Victory maybe for for
Magnus because he then he's better
prepared and might get a better position
I think that's uh that's important so
we'll see if uh if Yan is gonna play
play play fast now or or to or he will
think more yeah it's really interesting
as well we just see the stockfish uh
kind of suggestions there for black and
stockfish does suggest your move uh
pushing the black pawn to G6 to stop the
White Knight coming in uh as the best
move for Black by a mile and it's also
the most natural so we'll probably see
it on the board
um black could also develop the Knight
it's actually not as bad as it looks
apparently although it looks pretty bad
uh in the line that we showed yeah I
guess the justification would be that
black can challenge the Rooks after the
White Knight jumps in
maybe that would maintain the balance
for black but
I'm expecting that pawn push to be
played and then uh okay and then we'll
see the justification
we've been saying you know control the
night circuit and there you go the pawn
move is on the board yeah that was
interesting upon me actually we saw him
fiddling with a piece and then somehow
he still managed to make his move
without uh breaking that kind of
fidgeting routine so multitasking
so I do want to put to you a question
from Rahul on Twitter who asks us yep he
thinks it's going to be another exciting
day but they're Curious by how many ELO
points Eli rating points will Magnus or
napoleoni increase if they win the
championship hmm it's a good question
and uh that actually depends on the
score so Magnus for example could win uh
he could win by just one point he could
win six and a half five oh wait no seven
and a half
yeah exactly he could win seven and a
half six and a half and I think he'll
still lose a bunch of rating points
because every game game that is drawn
he'll lose one or two points and uh any
game he wins he'll gain six so
yeah it will still balance out and okay
uh meanwhile white has played a move not
the important move I was suggesting but
a similar idea just pushing that pawn
two squares forward and maybe just
creating at the square for the White
Knight to jump back to the square at
that pawn used to sit on and then
re-route itself so what do you think
about this poor move because I must
admit my mouth dropped a little bit
because one thing that I've always been
taught is like you should always try to
block your opponent's diagonals and with
that pawn move you've just allowed that
Bishop to have free reign towards the H2
Square I know I understand it's not a
middle game so to speak because this is
the main game so King safety doesn't
play so much of a role but uh what do
you think surprising I I like to move
it's very aggressive and as David
pointed out the important plan is you
want to reroute the knights from H4 to
to G2 because it's really not doing much
on H4 anymore after black played Ponto
G6 so it can never go to F5 you want to
get it to G2 so let's say if black
where's the play Knight D7 now develop
the knights then you can play Knight to
G2
and at some point if if white gets time
it will be great if he could play Pawn
to G5
okay so uh yeah
E3 first yeah on to G5 and then if
White's Knight would get to E3 now
suddenly we see the pawn on G5 is doing
a really good job because black cannot
really protect upon like usually he
would have to go Knight to F6 but that
one on G5 restricts restricts him so and
also Magnus played it fast so it should
be pretty confident yeah now
actual reaction after minus this move
was that it actually jumped up quite a
bit for janapomnia it was thinking for
quite a long time on the computer before
it corrected itself towards the middle
you said that this looked quite
aggressive for Magnus this pawn move
what can you say about the game so far
then is it looking like Magnus is going
to be ambitious in this game
it looks a bit calm now because the
Queens are traded off and it's almost
symmetrical but we see the pawns are a
bit different on the on the queen side
but Magnus is definitely looking
aggressive at the same time because he's
playing very fast and there is this
imbalance with the pawn on D5 being weak
and the pawn on C3 being weak
so also it's it feels like this is kind
of uh minus position
he's usually very good in these end
games well while Leon is known to be a
very like aggressive dynamical player so
maybe he thinks that uh he's pretty
happy with this this opening where he
can put some pressure on him do you
think this is more a Magnus type of
position compared to game two where it
was Catalan it was really wild it was
really fun to watch but maybe Magnus
felt a bit uncomfortable in those
complications do you think he's just
going back to basics now
uh minus has been known for being like
the best player to grind out this uh
slightly Edge end games so he's starting
against us right many times yeah against
me and against you against me in Norway
chess I experienced that and uh I think
he would be pretty confident even if he
gets a slight Edge in the end game like
if black plays precise it might end in
the draw but
uh he I mean he's not risking anything
and he seems to be in preparation so I
think he's happy with this so Jan played
Knight to D7 as we
as we point said was logical yep
yeah developing in the night and now I
think mines is probably gonna play his
Knight to G2
quickly again you think
yeah I guess so because the Knight is
really not doing anything on H4 so it
will go to G2 there we go Magnus does
retreat his Knight
as expected and maybe this will be the
first big long thing we'll see from
Napoleon actually because it's a
critical moment already maybe yeah I
mean how would you organize the pieces
if you were playing with the black
pieces
good question Ivanka I would probably
sit there for 20 minutes trying to
figure out where to put the black pieces
especially where to put that black
knight which lacks kind of a stable
Square from where to protect its uh
Central Pawn so I mean because the
alternatives are like you just ignore
the Central Pawn and maybe go on the
counter attack so the moves that I'm
thinking of maybe developing the Knight
attacking a pawn and getting ready to
spring in with that night into the
center other things I see are just about
putting the Rooks to an open Line the
sea lion attack the pawn
this backward one yeah
you could do a combination of those I
guess this would maybe just force white
to defend passively with a bishop and if
now you jumped in or if you want jump in
any time you know what I'm going to say
I know exactly
I'm gonna push this point exactly
exactly it's a pretty good move but the
answer is quite faster okay he does go
for this move actually just uh trying to
attack a phone it's a backward Pawn very
sensible I'm I'm very curious do you
guys think Jan is still in preparation
or not surely not right it's such a I
mean how could you prepare this unless
magnus's played such uh such a language
but it's very surprising to play so fast
because they are on move 20 and uh
unless this night move uh or move 18
that Magnus has played was the top
suggestion of the computer
okay it's not on this particular one but
I imagine if you're working with super
computers which both of the players are
and if the computer says hey this is the
best move with this idea then maybe they
are both in prep because they both seem
to be
blitzing out the moves look at Magnus
there he's looking down but I don't
think he's looking at the board he's
just trying to again go back into his
Memory Palace and try and pick out what
uh the best moves were there he's just
trying to remember his analysis I think
rather than calculate anything new well
what do you think Ariana are they an
opening prep I actually think so I feel
they have to be because why would you
play for young why would he play that
move so fast if you have like one hour
one hour and 40 minutes on the clock and
it's moved 20. uh it's already like
Midway to move 40 so you have a lot of
time it wouldn't make sense to play so
fast I think he was like trying to
remember when he spent five minutes some
moves before
so how rare is that and move 21 that we
probably have two players in opening
prep trying to remember the right move
yeah it's relatively rare especially
because this isn't the most forcing
variation sometimes there's an I mean
for example some lines of the Sicilian
Defense they'll be very forcing lines
where you have to memorize 20 25 moves
just to survive but this one there have
been five or six options at every turn
for both sides especially earlier Magnus
as Ivanka mentioned he didn't choose the
most popular line again he didn't choose
the most popular continuation so uh I'm
I'm 100 sure Magnus is in preparation at
least until this move but for Yan to be
as well that would be mightily
impressive well we have heard from Peter
Heine has coached that their main goal
is to get out of the opening they want
the two players to fight against each
other because they think that Magnus
then is the best player can we see that
Magnus is trying that to bring up
something new with every single move
he's definitely trying to do that we saw
before that he didn't choose the main
move but he was like choosing the second
or third main move his goal is to try to
get him out of preparation because if
it's human against human we all know
like minuses uh the the better player so
he it feels bad for him when the young
plays Rook to see it fast he it just
feels so good when your opponent starts
to think and you know he's out of book
and I know the position well Magnus
played fast now so that's nice at least
Bishop to F4 is pretty surprising we
didn't but it's the computer's Top
Choice yeah I think he just spent two
minutes there remembering and tried to
work out what happens next because I
said there were no forcing lines but
this does initiate some really forced
moves right
um I mean if back black now takes the
Bishops and blacks Rook can come and
grab a pawn we'll see lots of Trades and
lots of exchanges and I wouldn't be
surprised if Magnus has worked out what
to do there past move 25
um there is a sorry there's an
interesting variation now if black were
to trade off those Bishops okay so
blacks I mean black has to make a choice
with this bishop either you run away or
you trade right so if you take which is
the most natural yeah and then take the
pawn on C3 it looks looks logical then
uh White can take the pawn on D5 okay
and then the black Rook has to move
let's say to C4 maybe okay C4 yep or
yeah B3
maybe Magnus has planned this smooth
Rook E7 which looks pretty strong you
can jump into the position attacking
Black's Knight and this Knight actually
is tied down this Knight has to defense
and pawns itself but you can't defend it
if you try and defend this Knight then
suddenly we see her white positions with
knights are so tricky because this guy
is going to deliver a deadly Fork we see
Rook takes Knight sacrificing and a
nasty double attack so uh next move
white we'll take the Black Brook and be
a peace up so this is magnus's idea just
to go extremely active and if black does
take and then take again I think this is
inevitable right we'll take this pawn
and next move guaranteed that he'll jump
in with his Rook
um so does that beg the question of
whether Yan should even take this bishop
for example maybe he can Retreat just
together the square for the white Rook
I guess he's going to do that because
taking the bishop the variation looks
pretty forced he's struggling to defend
the D5 pawn and then Rook E7 was always
in the air as as you showed yeah so
Bishop Buffet looks looks more logical
and then yeah I'm curious if Jan will
also make that move fast I hope he's uh
out of gonna bear a preparation now I
mean he's not on the board but he might
come back and play instantly something
tells me that they are both in
preparation and okay this is not the
strongest computer I have to say that
I've got a computer engine but the Top
Choice is actually Bishop takes Bishop
she takes Bishop anything else is kind
of like ah it's a little bit passive wow
so it's not necessarily about this move
it's about the follow-up though yeah
yeah exactly he would love to play
Bishop takes Bishop but he needs to be
100 sure about how to kind of continue
after that
uh yeah then we probably missed some uh
some good move for black in that
variation trying to figure out what I
can I can run you I can run you through
what the computer says maybe after the
Rook does get to each and maybe then
black just moves the Knight and just
that's right it just gives the B6 points
yeah so okay we have to show the
schedule because Magnus right now he's
calculating we see him heading hands
he's trying to work out this whole
variation and it's not actually to do
with retreating the bishop Ivanka take
us away yeah so it's uh Bishop takes
Bishop just like you guys said Knight
takes and uh after this big captures The
Rook takes porn the Knight comes and
jumps into the Santa attacking The Rook
uh once again you guys chose the most
accurate uh um plays out they they
wanted to put the Rook on the um
D3 Square attacking the pawn and then
the big idea is that once The Rook comes
in the night just moves
and uh safe at home they're confusion is
just saying this is all good black has
got it under control wow white is teeny
tiny bit better
not enough to win so this looks like
it's losing upon white can grab a pawn
with his Knight but then the black root
just slides across
and a bit of a problem for white this
Knight is attacked this Pawn is attacked
you can't keep everything together and
we could see a scenario for example if
whitesnite drops back when everything
just gets traded off and we could see a
whole bunch of Trades and we could end
up in a position like this one where
it's just a dead draw three pawns on one
side against three pawns and how many
moves is that David just uh this is what
I think this would be more 28.
it's deep preparation but the players
aren't allowed to offer a draw to move
40 so we'll just move around and just
move around and repeat a position but
imagine we could be in for a very short
day though and Magnus had in hands he
won't be happy if that's the case this
would be a bad
um a bad day for Magnus so what can he
do to avoid this then and to bring it in
well either he has to take a passive
Choice which would not be the computer's
Top Choice or he has to kind of accept
it is a pretty forcing variation right
is there any way to vary it's too late
for a passive choice I think if you want
to play Passive if you want to keep the
tension maybe just a offend your Pawn
with your bishop and you say okay yeah
the game will go on and uh who knows
what will happen but now after he's
initiated all these trades it's forcing
right this is capture white has to take
back okay this is a capture why it
should take back that just goes on like
that but honestly I think we have to
give big credits for to Jan for his
amazing preparation it's it's really
incredible like minus was choosing
second move third move uh of the of the
Mainland and then the arm just blitzes
out and yeah he's so well prepared and
then it's I mean minus didn't let's say
if Jan were to trade the Bishops and
take the pawn it would probably end up
in a draw a position where he showed but
mine it's very hard for Magnus to
like
um assume that he will know that you
don't expect your opponent to just
splits out all those 25 moves and no
sideline yeah I was just gonna ask you a
bias actually if you were both second
for Magnus just say and you saw the
scenario where napomniachi has kind of
predicted everything that you've
prepared your your uh I want to say
student but that's not the right word
yeah Magnus four would you be worried as
a second
yep it's demoralizing right it's like
you throw everything at this guy and he
just knows all the replies he knows what
to do and uh does it mean like a change
of strategy is needed yeah it's it's
really hard to deal with uh like minus
change the first move and testing yarn
in in Petrov goes for Sidelines and even
there is like remembering all his uh
stuff so it's it's hard to ask a second
what you should do then but you just I
guess you just have to like switch from
opening and up to opening and hope hope
for the best to try to catch him in some
Sidelines yeah yeah like you could try
seven different openings with white but
then just if you catch them once
um and it looks like that hasn't
happened today but I mean I would be
telling telling Magnus maybe to be less
direct because Catalan is quite a direct
opening and there are lots of forcing
lines
this one as well it's just led to an
endgame very quickly
but then again if you choose a less
direct line that maybe isn't necessarily
the best objectively in a world
championship match if it backfires or if
you get outplayed as white then
then that isn't necessarily a good
choice either so
um and yeah it's not risky at all this
variation for white but the reward is
not great either yeah I also have a
question from chess X dronzer who asks
do you think that this long number of
draws in the world championships
previously and now is actually getting
to Magnus more than his opponents is he
pushing himself now
that's a very good question
um I know in 2018 he was getting
frustrated with all those draws and also
he at the time he was world number one
but he was only a couple of points ahead
of uh Fabiano caruana and he I think he
was just too scared to lose because if
he lost one game Carolina would have
overtaken him as world number one
um so all of those drawers I think he
found it frustrating and karyakin as
well when there were a few drawers in
the middle of that match he was finding
that mightily
annoying but this one is still early so
I don't think it's on his mind too much
but if it's all draws up until the
halfway point maybe we'll see him
cracking
uh it wouldn't be the first time we've
seen Magnus frustrated yeah how about
you
yeah definitely it feels more
frustrating for Magnus than his uh
opponent because he's like the
Challenger and the draws are completely
okay I mean he doesn't doesn't mind it
but minus feels like he's a best chess
player so he he really wants to win some
classical games and the fact that Jan
just let's say if he makes a draw easily
here it just feels really bad with white
that you can't put any pressure on him
even because for Magnus to go in the
opening is just to manage to get a game
but that's that's not easy these days
when Euro Pond is so well prepared
um yeah it's it's tough he has to think
about some other opening for that for
the next game I think I had an 18 world
championship match games in a row
where's the draw for Magnus if this one
is a draw that is a huge number none of
the games against Corona in 2018 ended
up with a winner everyone has predicted
that that's not going to happen in this
one it's 14 games two more games you can
take some more risks the styles of these
two players people are saying there will
be some decisive games you still still
think they will save it I'm 99 sure we
will see some blood some decisive games
I think 14 draws in a row is so unlikely
yeah I think especially as we kind of in
the second half of the uh in the match I
think players will be starting to take
more risks here and there or maybe
starting to lose their patience
um the problem actually they're just
looking off to the side slightly strange
body language uh one thing I should say
as well is that on birthdays it's very
rare to see draws oh normally players
they win on their birthday or they lose
on their birthday like two weeks ago I
lost on my birthday there is a bit of a
birthday curse but Magnus of course was
one on his birthday a few times and
yeah it's very very strange to see a
quieter game so maybe there's still some
life left in this one yeah and we're
gonna to head down to Dubai Tanya is
standing with the father of the birthday
boy Henrik Carlson
absolutely Kai we are inside the chest
24 Lounge where team magnuses and with
me is magnus's Dad Hendrick hi Henrik hi
there firstly congratulations on
magnus's birthday thank you
Tommy how was it have you guys
celebrated already on the rest day or is
it going to be tonight
frankly today they're playing at
important chess game so I know that
there's one thing he's hoping for on his
birthday but with regard to cake that's
going to be tomorrow night I think I do
see a nice cake on one of the tables
here that's for me
you know henric tell me one thing does
my
princess patch is pretty serious
business and he's not even turning
around numbers so I think today is all
about the chess game
we had a rest day yesterday he played
some football I think he's enjoying
himself hopefully
now when we met you last Henrik it was
at the start of the match and now we are
three games down we're into game four
there must be a certain routine that
must have been established can you tell
us a little bit about a normal game day
what's that like for team Magnus
well of course Magnus wants to get up at
a certain point and then we need to
prepare some food and it's a bit
uncertain whether he wants one or two
meals and
we kind of had to make sure that things
are efficient and pleasant for him and
if he wants some activities that the
right people are available and then by
now as you say we know the routine with
the cars and the entrance and that works
very smoothly so uh
now it's up to the players and I think
we're gonna have a fun game today as
well and is there any special right
before the game sort of a routine that
Magnus has just at the start to get into
the zone of playing
Evan you were mentioning about having
this support system around to make sure
that everything goes according to plan
uh yesterday there was this football
game we saw a lot of magnus's friends
and family around him of course that's
huge support but is there also purpose
and intent to make it as normal as
possible in this very high tension match
and that's a very good point and
therefore like the fact that his
sister's son one-year-old is there is
maybe also important because that's an
element that is kind of innocent and
open and you need to kind of relax in
any possible way that you can and forget
about the match
very nice all right and while I was in
the chest 24 Lounge Henrik I saw this
amazing book a life in pictures of
Magnus Carlson let me try and get it up
it's this one and I want to bring your
attention to this Photograph right here
and it says
it says a year off from school to travel
to chess tournaments all over Europe
when you look at this and you look at
Magnus I don't know how old was he here
that's a good question
I'm not sure 12 maybe 13 13 probably
and now you see him fighting for his
fifth world championship title it's been
a long journey uh you've obviously been
through it what is that one human
quality that Magnus has that's bought
him so far
he really wants to win
speaking of really wanting to win I'm
sure this one has some good memories to
it absolutely of course the first world
championship match is something unique
Larger than Life as I think I mentioned
this was in Chennai 2013 so looking at
it after almost eight years still brings
up good memories it's like yesterday
all right thank you so much Henrik for
your time and yes that is magnus's Dad
with a sneak peek into magnus's life
outside the board
thank you so much Tanya and it's really
nice to hear from Henrik Magnus he
really wants to win we had quite a few
moves on the board it's exactly what
David and Ariana numenka took us through
what do you say right now for the
position Simon yeah I mean I think I
have to Echo what David Ivanka and Aryan
said basically they're um very impressed
with Yan's preparation
um this was a line I don't know if
anyone could really predict that uh
would occur on the board and it seems
like Jan is just finding all the top
moves and uh it's basically followed the
analysis that was discussed and
um you have to say it's going to head
towards the draw I mean there's still
play left they have to make 40 moves so
something could happen but extremely
impressive preparation from Yan I which
I did not expect myself in in a line
where Magnus is playing sort of third or
fourth choice yeah
um I think opening wise is it's always
easy to say in hindsight what you should
do
um I know David uh himself he uh when he
plays he he plays uh I think as Magnus
even said old Manchester you know he he
plays the reti he plays stuff where you
keep a lot of pieces on the board and
I'm just wondering if later on in the
match if this if Yan's preparation is
gonna be so strong if uh if maybe uh you
know this is something Magnus should try
to do just play something where the
pieces remain on the board where you
don't have forcing lines like this so
it's uh yeah maybe something will have
to change we have to wait and see yeah
Magnus the world champion he is thinking
we're going to go back in chess history
and talk about another world champion
now assignment it's the first one in the
line of world champions Max other quite
a difficult last name to pronounce Max
what was uh what was he known for
well Max over was um a world champion
quite a short period of time and I think
it was a big surprise at the time when
he became world champion because he took
the throne from alakai and uh alakain
was probably the strongest player the
stronger player at the time but uh it
was said he he was maybe a little bit a
little bit arrogant you know a little
bit overconfident maybe even was
drinking a little bit too much at the
time there was a rumor but um max over
from Holland
um Holland's only ever world champion
came along and he won the world
champions and Max server was a very
exciting player
um very like full frontal attacks so he
goes straight for his opponent King and
his game this game's really nice to
watch because I think they're quite in
some ways okay simple you saw as
opponent's king he attacked it and um he
was yeah very exciting world champion
and in Holland they even have the max
over Center so which is really cool I've
been there myself nice library in the
center of Amsterdam and uh yeah of
course he's a bit of a hero over there
yeah and I heard rumors so he was a
mathematician and you know that's maybe
something that most people would think
that are all chess players really good
at math would that be your favorite
subject in school
there is if I speak to any non-chess
players they sort of assume okay you're
you're uh you're good at chess you must
be really clever and then they sort of
get to know me and they're like actually
yeah forget about that but they actually
in general they think there's a
relationship between maths and chess and
uh I I don't know I don't think many
Studies have been done this maybe
there's more of a relationship between
uh chess and stuff like music you have a
bit creative right he's very into
classical music yeah like a rhodium like
other people as well
um that could be possible I expect if
you you know do excel at chess you have
to be able to study you have to have
good concentration so it is generally
going to be a good thing yeah
um he was also an amateur boxer
apparently which is which is quite crazy
um so uh I don't know maybe that's where
chess boxing comes from then possibly
possibly yeah he doesn't really look
like a boxer but you you never know and
um he he was like say just a really
interesting world champion and played
some great full frontal attack hacking
chess you have a position up on the
board here I do so this was a game he
played with the black pieces against
tartikova another leading chess player
at the time and um you can see that
Black's pieces on the board here are
sort of all surrounding the white king
and again I think this demonstrates the
sort of his attacking play where you
have your opponent's king you have your
Rook Queen they're sort of hovering
around there and you've got to find a
way to break defenses down and he loves
sacrificing he would always spot uh
opportunities to attack and he now went
in with a check and this is attacking
the king and the queen it has to be
captured and that's one piece is
sacrificed and now he goes for a second
sacrifice here it uses the rook and this
is drawing the king further down the
board so the king really has to take
this Rook now and the whole point of
this play is that his Queen can swing
over to this Square ah giving another
check and eventually you have a check
here and you will pick up this queen and
win the queen or Checkmate so it's it
was like these combinations where he
went straight for his opponent's king
which made him a really attractive
player really really uh nice to watch
and simple attacking chess yeah
beautiful now um he wasn't world
champion for that long only two years he
was I guess maybe a clear number one in
his era as a world champion but you
mentioned he was into boxing obviously
the only Dutch world champion as well
does he still have influence on Chester
is he one of those who had big influence
on chessler yeah I mean I I definitely
think so I mean just the whole Fitness
thing uh We've mentioned before but if
you go back to maybe the the first kind
of world champions they were notoriously
not that fit but you can see now with
Magnus Carlson on the rest day he he was
out there playing football he keeps
himself incredibly incredibly fit and um
this this idea of exercise being healthy
healthy mind healthy body is is really
important and if you're playing 14 games
of Chess day after day then you've got
to be able to stay awake you know and
not make mistakes so I think this is
this is an important thing that we can
yeah we can see all the top chess
players now they take their Fitness
seriously Magnus Carlson is still
thinking about his next move now Max
over the only Dutch world champion in
history but later on there has been some
huge chess Talent from the Netherlands
in each Geary good and fun forest and
we're gonna head down tutoring who's
standing at the Expo 2020 in Dubai at
the Dutch Pavilion and I guess they're
going to be some people very proud of
their former world champion
well that is absolutely right I'm here
at the Dodge Pavilion uh here's a talk
first a little bit about Max over so he
may not have this great legacy as the
great Champion uh that maybe Al yankin
has but he actually has a huge Legacy
that are not not a lot of people know
about every time every single time you
play a game of chess
you are in touch with Max Irvin because
he was actually discussed a
mathematician and back in his day the
draw rules for threefold repetition was
that if you repeat a position if you
repeat a sequence of moves three times
the position will be clear the declared
a draw
as a mathematician Mac server said one
evening looking at the board and it
occurred to him that you can actually
have an infinite game of chess under
these rules he developed something
called the 2A more sequence to prove
this and he had to become feeder
president and change the rules so we can
have the three full repetition rules we
have now and we also have as you said
some Dutch person here who may be very
very proud if you could just step one
yes thank you very much uh of the great
Max Irvin this is Magnus Magnus do you
happen to be a fan of the other Madness
of course I'm so excited that he's
playing here at Expo today and uh
actually I heard it's his birthday so
I'm watching all the best of luck and
hopefully he went to them well uh and as
a Dutchman do you know who Max irva is
yes Maxwell is one of our Dutch Legends
Dutch Grandmaster the first one actually
and he was known for being one of the
most logic players of all time so always
very objective never taking any
unnecessary risks while playing chess
and always putting the right position in
place
that's very interesting uh Magnus can
you tell me uh besides being a chess fan
and obviously being happy to be here for
the world championship what is your what
are you working with here at your
Pavilion yeah so just like chess the
Netherlands Pavilion it's uh it's a
strategic game so the question is you
know how can we create a circular
biotope in the desert was more than 45
degrees
um and so here the Netherlands Ingenuity
not just logic but creativity as well we
presented an Innovative solution that
allows us to capture water from the air
and harvest the whole ecosystem of
edible plants including oyster mushrooms
well thank you that is absolutely
fascinating Magnus uh I hope you enjoyed
this small segment and now back to you
guys in the studio
thank you so much for tuna at the Dutch
Lounge where of course they're very
proud of Max over the only Dutch world
champion in history my name is Carlson
Norwegian only the the only Norwegian
world champion thinking for now almost
10 minutes what is he thinking about I
think it's a philosophical question does
he continue fighting just for the sake
of trying or does he force a draw and uh
kind of go back with his tail between
his legs thinking okay it's a draw with
white it's not bad but it hasn't been
great either and right now maybe we can
just show a couple of variations because
Magnus he's in calculation mode maybe
his opening preparation continues maybe
it's run out already but if he takes
this Pawn I think we'll see a quick draw
if he takes this Pawn the black Rook
will slide across and no matter where
white goes with the Knight Black's Rooks
will start gobbling up these pawns and
actually all of the pawns on the queen
side will just disappear with will
liquidate the position and it will just
end up in a draw uh if Magnus however
wants to play ambitiously if he wants to
try and win he might give a check and
actually just while rooner was talking
to myself and Aryan and Ivanka we were
discussing what might happen so the
black king would have to move why could
you give another check
maybe Magnus could force a draw like
this he could bring kind of continue
checking with his Knights but if he
wants to win he could maybe push forward
with a pawn hoping for Rook takes Pawn
with a nasty night check night Fork
attacking and winning one of the black
Rooks but if black ignores this and
pushes his own Pawn then we could see a
race the white Pawn will run forward the
black porn will run forward and white
could even push forward now because
there are still some night forks for
example Knight takes Pawn where he could
give up rook temporarily and win
material with a nasty double attack but
the problem is you do allow blacks Pawn
forward and I mean in a position like
this it involves so much risk for both
sides but I mean Magnus unless he thinks
unless he thinks that uh he's forcing a
win here I don't reckon he can go for
this it's just too much risk right a
minimal reward as well I mean maybe best
case scenario these pawns kind of get
traded off for each other somehow and
it would end up in a draw anyway so
world champion head in hands deciding
what to do and
what do we think guys is this the moment
for guess the move because we might not
get another opportunity uh is this the
moment so Magnus he's gonna bring his
Knight forward with a check or he's
going to take a Pawn on the queen Satan
come on guys it's guess the move time
[Music]
all right we're asking everyone at home
to tweet what move you think Magnus
Carlsen will make maybe you only have a
few seconds maybe only a few minutes so
you have to be quick tweet your moves to
c24 live yeah because there's an awesome
prize at stake it is one year membership
of G chess which is the first ever
website where you can just put up a
chest position and you can search that
position on chess databases chess
articles chessable and of course YouTube
so it's an amazing prize and you've got
to tweet your answer using the hashtag
c24 live and I guess the big question
then iron is if Magnus is forced to
maybe put this in a very forced kind of
Jewish situation or if we will see some
ambition from him unfortunately at this
point uh I think we're gonna move 26
yeah like yarn has played so accurately
his minus looks a bit frustrating I mean
it's not to a trail to say this I don't
it's not he cannot really do much I
think uh he has to either take the pawn
or give the check on F6 as David showed
and then I think he's gonna if he checks
on F6 I think he's gonna check on E8 and
back to F6
with the Perpetual or if you take some
B6 those pawns on the queen side are
gonna be traded off
and we're gonna see sir Joe I can't
really see what he can he can try I mean
he's really like this but they're trying
to find some life in the position but
it's it's very hard to see it yeah if uh
I mean if you were in magnus's shoes
right now would you at least spend 10 20
minutes just trying to figure out if
there is a way to maybe force an
opponent actually to be accurate I mean
he has so much time so if he spends like
20 30 minutes uh just to double check he
can he can definitely do that like he
has nothing to lose yeah you take that
time with you I guess to the next game
yeah so I'll spend it now yeah but I
guess he knows that he doesn't have
anything and within the next five
minutes I think he's gonna just realize
uh that he has to go for go for the draw
because why would he uh maybe he doesn't
want to spend too much energy we'd
either just get finished with the game
and rest for the night for the next one
yeah all right well we do have guests to
move everyone so tweet what you think
will be the next move for Magnus cross
and we're gonna head down to Dubai and
here uh what the people around these two
players think will be happening in this
game now
flying Sky I think definitely a puzzling
decision here by Magnus many of us him
coming out after I stay with the white
pieces were expecting something slightly
more aggressive but it has been a Petrov
and it looks like the world champion
hasn't gotten much out of the opening to
take us through what's happened I've got
with me Grandmaster Hans Neiman Hans
first question were you surprised with
one E4 I was definitely surprised with
24 I felt that in the Catalan Magnus had
great preparation he surprised him
really well Jan was first made some
difficult decisions and despite Magnus
sort of overpressing in that game I
really felt that his preparation was
great so I was surprised that he didn't
go for the Catalan again but I think in
E4 maybe he felt that John was a Target
and the Petrov is certainly also another
huge surprise I did not expect that for
sure
very different from the usual night of
stuff we see from Yan yeah I think I'm
beyond that we're seeing here is really
really he's impressed me with his
opening play I think although we see the
position sort of petered out into very
drawish position
the preparation that Magnus showed was
really impressive I think and this whole
idea was I was really impressed but Yan
just seems to be Stone Cold and just
brush it off and just equalizing without
any any problem so I've been really
impressed with the yawn that we've seen
in this match and uh you know I'm
looking forward to the future games we
spoke to Vladimir putkin earlier and he
mentioned well it is the Russian defense
so can't be all that surprising but
completely agree with you Petrov will be
interesting to so to know if Magnus was
expecting it or not can you take us
through a couple of critical moments in
the game yeah so there are a few
secrets so obviously e45 Knight F3
Knight F6
um I don't think that this was such a
huge surprise like in these matches all
of the top players are preparing for all
the main openings so it's not like Jan
plays the Petrov and Magnus is like oh
I've got nothing he's I'm sure he's got
so many ideas he can Splash off in his
back pocket but I don't think he was
sort of focusing on it so unless I
forget I mean this was a main opening in
the 2018 World Championship Match as
well yeah this is sort of Fabiano's main
opening so I can I think we all there's
no question of whether there's no the
question is not whether Magnus is
prepared against Bachelor of a lot like
I there's probably so many ideas left
over from this match against Fabiano
um so it definitely wasn't a surprise
but I guess considering how things gone
it's John definitely was a success for
him all right so so how did this
continue so I'll continue with
um Knight takes E5 D6 Knight F3 Knight
takes E4 D4 D5 all this is pretty
different this is all pretty typical
this is sort of regular Theory now
Bishop D6 is is uh this is sort of one
of the main main lines now after castles
castles C4 the ideas are sort of putting
pressure in the center the knight in u4
is really critical so if you're C6 there
are a few ideas here the main line is
actually Knight to C3 and after this
trade there's really deep Theory like
the Petrov is is very concrete opening
so it's very important that you know a
lot um so Magnus just play Rook E1 which
is sort of another secondary move and uh
aroni has played this a lot recently
after Bishop 5 Queen B3 Queen D7 now and
I I knew this position I've seen this
Mission many times with the move Knight
E3 definitely was a surprise
um it's clearly you know offering some
liquidation and after Knight takes C3
you don't take back immediately because
of the bishop hanging intermezuma Bishop
takes F5 and after Queen takes F5 B
takes C3 it seems like we've traded off
some pieces
seems like block is okay but there's
still some pressure right because this
B7 Pawn there's some tension between the
pawns on C4 and D5 so after B6 Pawn
takes D5 Pawn takes D5 this idea Queen
B5 is really interesting
um because it's sort of putting pressure
asking the question of how blast can
develop the pieces are because Knight D7
is a little bit awkward maybe it's a C4
idea taking advantage of the pin on you
know here on the queen
um
like nine age four yeah yeah exactly
this D5 Pawn is definitely the central
idea of putting pressure on this so
Magnus decided to play Queen D7 and it
should be noted that you can play Queen
takes D5 because if you know Bishop
takes H2 very common idea
um opening at the attack on the queen so
I think this was even perhaps no
preparation playing A4
um and all this has been played really
okay it has so that you know that's
that's not surprising the Pet Shop is an
extremely theoretical opening so after
the trade of Queens
um Jan played A5 which is a very natural
move because this Pawn is really
restricting the natural development of
the night and if you didn't let's say if
you played a move like Knight D7 in the
long terms you can play A5 this is sort
of a backwards pawn and it could be a
big weakness so A5 is sort of creating
you know a past um Pawn
um so it's a question of whether you
want to take it or you want to leave it
so here's Here Comes here's where Magnus
preparation is sort of Unleashed right
he plays with Knight H4
um essentially threatening out of five
and if if you make the bishop move then
you know you could have some you know
check any side winning the pawn so after
G6 now this is where another he's still
continuing with the preparation G4
um
actually Magnus made the move Knight H4
in 35 seconds so that's definitely he's
still in prep and then Yan took about
five and a half minutes and made the
move G6 as you were pointing out against
the idea of Knight F5 so do you think
this is the moment when Jan was out of
his books I think so I think this idea
with Knight H4 G4 was his team pull I
said okay this is a new idea he's
definitely not going to do it because
it's not something that the computer
initially suggests so this is sort of
how his team is probably approaching it
um but I guess the natural moves here
um led to some some type of equality so
after Knight to D7 the Knight comes back
to G2 the idea is to bring the bishop to
F4 again the entire play is around
attacking this D5 Pawn which is isolated
so after Rook have to C8 Bishop White's
got a weakness exactly right so so it's
sort of a fight between who's going to
get to you know who's going to get to C3
or are they going to get to D5 first so
I guess it sort of balanced out after
Bishop to F4 Bishop takes F4
Knight takes F4
Rook takes C3 and now after Knight takes
D5 Rook D3 Rook E7 Knight at fate we've
reached the sort of the position that we
have in the game and the unfortunate
thing for Magnus is although he showed
this amazing idea with Knight h4g4
it's just everything's it really looks
like it's about to liquidate like
there's so few pieces left on the board
there's not really like an imbalance in
this position that can lead to
to provoking a direct mistake right with
D4 G4 B5 is a little bit weak I just
don't really see how either side is
going to create an imbalance enough to
create a decisive result so I think here
things are going to liquidate soon
there's a possibility of sort of a force
draw with Knight of six King g798
a repetition right and this point you
don't really want to go to H6 it's a bit
awkward and after 96 there'd be some
unfortunate pressure and then you know
obviously here could lead to repetition
and after King James out of six this
would this would be a force draw
so obviously I think Magnus is thinking
can he pose any serious pressure here
does he have to take a draw it's sort of
an unfortunate as with the white pieces
it's tough psychologically to make that
decision
um so it'll be interesting to see what
happens but I definitely think that
Jan's defense against magnus's idea was
very impressive today so would you say
that looking at this opening that Jan
definitely had the opening Victory today
I wouldn't I wouldn't it's unclear to
say opening Victory I would say that the
idea that Magnus played was extremely
impressive and I would say that that
itself was an opening Victory but I
would say that the way that Jan
responded to that and handled that
pressure
um is sort of outside of the scope of of
the opening per se and more impressive
from a practical perspective so I would
say that in general Magnus has been
showing really impressive opening ideas
but Jan has been defending extremely
well against them
although we have it Grandmaster hunts
Neiman breaking down the opening action
for us and we've got a move by Magnus so
let's head over to the studio
thank you so much sananya after 22
minutes the move is on the board yeah I
was just gonna say that was a really
impressive recap of the whole game
so what's happening Hans was just
talking about the opening some nuances
there and talking actually about the
position and uh discussing the risk
involved for Magnus if he wants to play
for a win and talking of playing for a
win uh Magnus has given a check we're
not sure yet what his intentions are
next but we do have an answer to the
guess the move white did play Knight F6
check exactly all right well
we did have guests to move so Ivanka is
gonna now uh look I'm gonna sift through
because there are a lot of responses so
thank you very much for that and uh a
lot of people saying night check and a
lot of people saying capture the pawn
yeah so uh yep yep so I mean I like this
decision by Magnus he's still not
risking too much he can maybe repeat the
position later by giving some kind of
continuous night checks that's something
as well that Hans discussed there but uh
he is also asking napoleonchi maybe some
questions if he wants to play on
that variation we showed earlier with
Aryan
um yeah it does at least
kind of pose like one or two
questions to answer there we go the
first question has been answered uh
Black's King runs away from the check
that's the only safe Square as well
Black's King needs to defend some pawns
and it puts the pressure on the White
Knight for sure now I think we're gonna
see why tonight go up to the top of the
board and deliver another check and it
will be after Napoleon actually replies
there that we will discover magnus's
intentions and currently no players by
the board now you did see Hans neem on
there with Tanya analyzing the game so
far and uh Hans Neiman he actually made
a post game chorus on chessable every
single day it comes out impressively
quickly after the game and you can of
course check that out on chessable the
link is on the bottom here and it's free
for everyone to check out so you know
no half an hour maybe an hour after the
game you can maybe that's too quick yeah
I mean yeah Hans is a strong player good
friend of ours so yeah recommend that
course exactly yeah check it out now all
right Adian what do you think right now
will this be fizzling out to a draw
quite soon well now he's kind of forced
to play a knight to yeah track because
the night on F6 is hanging so when minus
comes to the board I expect him to make
that move pretty fast and then uh Jan
will play King back to G8 as we as we
showed before and then the question is
is mine is just going to repeat the
position and take a draw or he could
push the D5 Pawn
uh and that pawn cannot be taken as
David showed there is this Fork
but Jan is obviously not gonna gonna
fall for that he's probably gonna push
his A4 Pawn Magnus now made his move 98.
so yeah this is actually the current
position on the board and uh once black
does retreat the king this will be the
moment of truth will Magnus take the
draw will he repeat and go back or push
this Pawn forward Arian you mentioned
black pushing uh we had some discussions
here actually and the miners can always
like take the jaw even when they push D5
A4 so he could like play D5 first and
then play Knight F6 98.
or he can push the pawn to D6 black
pushes the pawn to A3 so we have a race
going to D7 and here it's it's an
important moment because black has to be
a bit careful he cannot push his Pawn to
A2 because white has a trick in the
position if you were to do that then
white could give a check with his Knight
to on F6 King to G8 to King to G7 and
then you have this very strong with Rook
E8
eliminating this uh rook and trying to
force the spawn through and actually
white wins material right yeah this
looks uh this looks bad for black so
instead of pushing the pawn to A2 black
has to be a bit careful but I think the
move Rook d8 just controlling the D7
pawns should uh should hold yeah just
ganging up on this guy three times now
and uh even if white has some annoying
Knight checks later on I think black
should be okay here it feels like this
one will disappear maybe white can get
this one in return but still a draw so
that's the question does Magnus uh once
Jan makes his move for example
recruiting the king does Magnus repeat
the position now or does he continue
playing knowing that it should be a draw
anyway but maybe along the way he can
some traps is this next move sort of
force free on the palm of natural
obviously has to move his King but could
he move it to another Square not
repeating possibly uh but no
no it's maybe one's risk too far yeah he
just wanted to defend the uh the pawn on
the F7 square that the white Rook who's
maybe eyeing up so so now the big
question right the big question will
Magnus move his Knight back repeating or
will he move his Pawn those are are
those two the only ones
to me they're the only ones which really
makes sense
um because any other options would allow
the Black Knight to jump in or the black
rook in the corner tattoo yeah and also
you have to remember that black has a
past Pawn you know we showed a very
scary line where black was advancing his
Pawn as far up the board so I agree with
you completely you know the time now is
time is now is what I wanted to say when
there's a race or a potential race every
move counts yeah and uh I just wanted to
announce that we do have a winner of Our
Guest the move competition the winner is
retro who tweeted I'm thinking Knight
goes to F6 check you are spot on and you
are the lucky winner of one year's
membership to G chess which is the first
ever chess website where you can just
put up a position on the board and you
can search that position on chess
databases chess articles
accessible short and sweet and YouTube
always like amazes me how on Earth can
you do that but with G chess you can so
congratulations retro and enjoy working
with yeah well DJs another very cool
online digital uh computer thing which
is very relevant in this match I mean
have you ever seen a world championship
match where computer prep has been this
relevant the players you know all the
way up until move 20s are in computer
prep yeah it's crazy it gets like more
and more relevant for every world
championship match because the
technology just goes forward so let's
say 10 years ago the computer prep was
much less relevant and uh it's much
harder to be so deeply prepared but the
engine are just like
just getting so strong that uh
you can prepare so deeply with them like
probably in two years it will even be
more so it's
too much yeah how can we get out of it
oh it's impossible now it's inescapable
I think but yeah as you say if you
compare this match to Carlson's first
match against Anand I mean there I don't
really remember any games that were
decided purely because of uh computer
prep or that fizzled out purely because
both players had memorized everything
um of course it affected the openings
and the kind of the course of the game
but still the positions were always full
of life in the middle game and
this one game two was still full of life
but apart from that
computers have had a big big stay is it
becoming even more important with memory
for chess players now then to memorize
these lines that you're analyzing on a
computer memory is so important because
before the match you look at all these
different opening variations
but you have so much time also so you
can remember them usually like one month
two months before the the match you have
all these files with opening analyzers
and you go through them every day just
trying to remember because if you don't
remember them
then it's not like really useful yeah so
but I'm sure like yond he has probably
played training games in this variation
gone gone through it many times and the
big problem these days is that it's just
very hard on the top top level to get a
playable position with whites because
black is just so deeply prepared
how much does computer preparation
affect your games these days are in like
do you I mean do you do the same thing
that I guess the players here have been
doing do you employ teams do you uh
study with computers before your big
events yeah it's definitely also very
important for me I would say as a good
GM level opening preparation is maybe 85
wow important for sure yeah because uh
when you're like a strong gym you're a
very good chess player so this the
margins gets very very small like uh and
then if you get a good position from the
opening you have very good chances to
win but if you don't usually a strong
Grandmaster would not make a mistake and
you would not be able to to win the game
so it's very important to be able to
surprise in the opening its place plays
a huge uh role but then also as you
mentioned then memorizing all the stuff
you study how do you practice your
memory what is a tip for young chess
players out there how to practice the
memory is is so important and Magnus uh
Magnus is known to have a very good
memory so usually when he sees something
he remembers it uh and I think it's just
like uh before an event going through
your analyzes and maybe played on the
board for me it's easier to remember
when I see it on the board or play play
some training games maybe practice it in
some Blitz are there techniques though
to practice your memory I had a I had a
story that when Fabiana Carano Was
preparing for the world championship it
took him months to memorize this uh in
fact opening the same Avenue the Petra
of defense or Russian defense and uh you
know they would practice every week you
know they will say what happens are you
what are you going to do after this
sacrifice and he would have to repeat
and it was like Aryan says putting up a
board and just practicing and practicing
and getting that feel for where your
pieces should go and if you're you know
in a critical position where your king
would Escape too
and it's about repetition as well that's
why chessable has become so popular even
among the really elite players in the
world just because you're forced to
repeat things you're forced to prove
that you remember and uh definitely
that's something that I maybe have
struggled with over the last couple of
years not playing as much over the board
it means you dedicate less time to
purely memorizing and that that makes it
kind of impossible to go into these
really kind of critical sharp openings
against the top players because if for
example Napoleon actually had made one
tiny slip on move 19 which is still
quite deep then he would have been in
trouble so uh yeah fine margins and
nowadays memory is important of course
you can freestyle a bit if you choose
certain types of openings but that comes
with a lot of risk well you are proof
that it is possible David in the in the
grand Swiss for sure yeah you said that
you know you struggled in every single
opening but just getting out of the
opening you were able to get that
amazing results yeah there was one game
I got surrounded
but yeah once you kind of get out of the
opening then you can feel a lot more
confident and uh yeah it helped that I
kind of played quite a narrow opening
repertoire there just
the Berlin against everything and one
Knight of three is White against
everything it's just uh that game you
got surprised on the move through you
you won against such a strong player so
exactly you can do it yeah you of course
also played that event darling you had a
great start in the tournament then a
little bit you know horrible finish okay
the start was like amazing yeah I think
I never started so well I had like a 28
30 performance and everything was going
well and then I didn't win a game I was
completely winning in game seven and
then I
um slowed the slow down and Miss many
chances so it was a unfortunate finish
but it was great to be there and play so
many strong players yeah and finally an
over-the-board tournament again and what
is your plans now going forwards uh
going forwards I actually don't have any
classical tournaments planned I'm
playing the world rapid and Blitz in uh
the Kazakhstan yeah in the end of
December then over the new year I
haven't planned anything I'm gonna try
to find some new tournaments in January
February we'll we'll see yeah wrapping
and Blitz yeah that's gonna happen right
right after this tournament or the world
championship match yeah I'm debating
playing as well but it's going to be so
cold there and it's cold here too it's
cold we'll see we'll see who used it
yeah true but Aaron we also know that
you've been second in Spanish giri for a
while is that something you will
continue to do okay we have an answer
from Magnus Carlsen he does not repeat
okay he does not repeat he does not go
for the draw this is good news great we
still have some more action all right so
this is Magnus Carlsen saying I'm gonna
try to push for a win yeah setting some
traps as well for example if the black
root goes and takes this Pawn the White
Knight will jump back with the check and
Magnus will win on the spot so uh
definitely some pitfalls for napony
actually to avoid of course he won't
blend into such obvious uh traps but
there are going to be some ideas lurking
beneath the surface that he still has to
work out so
I was gonna ask um something that uh was
asked on Twitter I mean are there any
possibilities that the white work that's
not really working it's in the corner of
the board is that able to you know
engage itself and put itself on the
seventh row yep um it would take a
couple of moves but once the Rooks align
uh for example if black just does
nothing if white can somehow uh get
these Rooks they will be very very
dangerous but this is the problem you
have to keep an eye on this Pawn from
yeah I mean it's running very very fast
it is what about your man could it be a
race you know where maybe white is in
time to do something yep so uh in the
current position here
might well be a race but the problem is
if black pushes immediately yeah I think
you're just a bit too slow with whites
you can bring the Rook across the form
pushes you bring it up and you're one
move away from delivering a nasty
Checkmate if black wasn't able to queen
or if it didn't come with check uh for
example if black would just make a move
this would end in the Arabian Checkmate
you're right it would be taught me the
name uh this would end in a very very
nice Checkmate the black king trapped in
the corner by the white Rooker Knight
but the problem is the pawn is just too
fast and
um yep unfortunately this guy would have
been able to promote in this variation
so yeah a great idea there from the
audience but depending on what the point
actually does maybe just a bit too slow
I think these are magnus's main ideas
though if he gets time to bring the Rook
up and to the seventh rank to team up
or just to push his pawn and hope for
the best all right well both of them
looks amazing you know you always told
me you want Rooks on the seventh line
seventh heaven yeah true uh if you can
get them there it's the dream but of
course it takes a bit of time to arrange
yeah the problem is that there's always
two players playing chess and you must
never forget and what your opponent
wants to do that is what I always do
when I play chess well don't worry you
know I also fade in the ground Swiss and
that was my big failing
I thought you know I was gonna pick up
the boys yeah it has so many good
positions but then my opponents they
threw us I know in the works as we say
they had plans as well they did and they
they did like to set some check mating
ideas out of nowhere
but that's yeah you hadn't played for a
while you're back you I mean the middle
games you were playing fantastically but
it's just the killer instinct that's
that's the first thing that is time
trouble I mean that's perhaps something
also but the players are very much aware
of you know when you haven't played for
a little bit you know you take a little
bit of time to reach those critical
decisions and and I had fantastic
openings fantastic middle games and then
things went wrong in the fourth hour you
know when the clock starts ticking down
and that's when I neglected the one
Golden Rule
look after your king
and out of nowhere you know I I but you
know it was a really good experience
yeah and I'm playing again actually I'm
going to be playing another tournament
oh what is it January it's a very cool
tournament oh what is that 10 men 10
women are going to be facing off each
other against each other on the Battle
of Texas Battle of sixes that is such a
cool name for tournament and uh the the
the difference with this tournament is
actually that on average the men and the
women are the same rating so it's going
to be very evenly matched all right
can't wait so is it like the the women
score points together and the men's
score points together yep
okay well who's your bet on there David
uh uh definitely the women
always
um there's one evening where we play on
giant chess sets it's men against women
and that's I mean that's where some of
the top men in the world like fashion
Carolina Nakamura they've all played but
women all seem to win so yeah
um okay I thought there might have been
yeah
it's funny he always brings his own tea
to the game and I played in Norwich as I
also uh saw that he doesn't like to take
the tea or the coffee from the flag but
he likes to bring his own
we saw that with a in the tour final in
the Champions chess tour with a niche
Anish kind of said well hang on a second
the tea here is a bit standard and we
brought in a very own tea person to come
and sell them specialty tea and I do
know that's because you know some teas
are very strong some especially some
Russian ones okay I'm talking about tea
here this is my favorite subject I'll be
here for hours
actually that brings me back to the
question about Anisha will you continue
your collaboration in future do you know
I hope so yeah
um well he didn't really have any
tournaments recently but uh yeah I might
might help and we still keep in touch
okay he's doing commentary with Judith
Nelson he's really pretty busy it's just
24 deep dive going on at the same time
and of course that's kind of to benefit
him with his openings his tournaments
but I guess you've picked up a few
things along the way yeah for sure now
since I started working with him I
learned a lot and uh I'm really like
honored to get the chance I'm sure he's
on it too okay so we know that the role
of a second is very much you know with
to help with opening preparation
um but what do you actually work on when
you're actually in a tournament I mean
is it mainly just psychological help
just saying the right things
or yeah so it's mainly open preparation
and just like uh social supports be
there for him as a friend and cheer him
up if he loses and how did you cheer him
up when he lose when he lost well go for
a walk just try to be a supportive uh
um it's uh yeah just you talk do you
talk about the game or do you try to
talk about something else like the
weather
um after the game finishes we definitely
talk about the game but let's say if it
goes badly you probably try to just
switch off completely from the chest and
think about something else so you you
get some some energy from from somewhere
else and then uh but if it goes well
it's it's more fun to talk about the
game yeah oh I can imagine like when he
uh in the tour finals he won the tie
breaks against Hikaru Nakamura and Blitz
chess right yeah that was the highlights
that was very cool yeah that must be we
could see him celebrate in each Geary
when uh winning that Blitz game all
right we are waiting for Jana ponyachi
to make his move
um his next move is is that gonna tell
us if I mean he's gonna be happy with
enjoying this game either way right yep
he's still facing some pressure as black
is not completely dead it's not
completely neutralized yet
um so he knows he needs to be accurate
and upon me actually I'm slightly
surprised he spent so long seven minutes
there because this move uh actually you
called it a while ago Aaron it's pretty
much automatic right yeah it's not clear
what else black could have done his
Rooks couldn't have been improved the
Black Knight couldn't move and he needed
to prevent the idea of the white work on
A1 joining in the game because you know
we saw that that was failing by one move
yeah exactly and uh here you go race
initiated okay and another critical
moment as Magnus I think he was just
struggling there with his pen maybe it
was running out of ink but uh okay he's
written down the move and now will he
give a check with his Knight or is he
going to push forward with a porn I was
curious about one idea like if uh Magnus
were to get very ambitious and push
forward with a pawn I mean is there any
hope for the Black Knight to activate
itself and
in that kind of situation maybe they
would not be a repetition of moves
anymore okay the Black Knight could jump
in now that the pawn has no longer uh is
no longer controlling the square and as
you mentioned Ivanka if the white knight
continues trying to draw uh kind of
repeat the position then the black king
has a new Square yeah exactly saying no
my friend yeah that's that's an
interesting move uh I was thinking maybe
if white can try to play a knight to C7
here okay uh just trading off those
lights so probably black will take you
take with the pawn
and now maybe a tree here if you push
the opponent like that would be a
mistake or maybe not a yeah maybe not a
mistake but you can play Maybe Rook E1
here with white double the Rooks wow
nice setting a trap if the black king
for example tries to cover this Square
to stop checking and you check anyway
yeah that's a that's a nice one of
sacrificing the rook and then you get a
new queen and a new Queen and white wins
the race but it seems even that would
maybe be a draw let's say if black
pushes the pawn after in this position
yeah A2
and white checks with the Rook black
takes
white takes King up to G7 so both sides
ready too well both sides make a queen
and then and we have Queen and rook and
four pawns against Queen rook and four
pawns but it's not clear I mean for
example if white flicks in a check first
maybe oh that's a very good move yeah I
don't know and the King has to come out
Black's King cannot take this Rook
because this would happen with check
um so if the black king has to come out
I'm not sure which direction then
this type of end game still a lot of
life left right yeah because the King on
H6 is actually in a bad situation and
usually in these types of positions it's
all about who gives the first check yeah
because both kings are pretty unsafe and
if white were to like check with the
queen on f8 and then bring his pawns up
with with Jack that could be pretty
pretty dangerous then again if there's
no Checkmate if blackened centralized
and start going for the white king then
maybe white is in trouble so if it's
really not clear here
but that is an interesting reaction if
if you only were to go
Knight to E6 yeah and that just shows I
mean this type of long forcing variation
that shows there's still life I mean it
looks like this is an endgame it's about
to fizzle out all the pawns are getting
traded but one move and then suddenly I
mean this type of forcing Direction with
Queens appearing on the board again
all three results possible so so in the
current position if Magnus pushes
forward then we'll see either black push
or introduce his Knight into the action
and anything can happen there if Magnus
wants to oh sorry not this move if
Magnus wants to maybe play the safe
approach he could give a check and then
either the repeat the position I was
also wondering what would happen for
example if white brings The Rook up
to try and threaten this guy in the
corner but maybe black just moves The
Rook
I was hoping for maybe a trade and then
depending on where the black king goes
maybe you can just take this pawn and
hope that black can't take back in the
center because of some night Forks some
night checks but
trees is the right square with his King
maybe it's a draw anyway a bit earlier
on so
um
and the current position
it's hard to find options other than
pushing forward or this night check yeah
the minus is just taking to force either
force a draw here with Knight F6 track
King 98 repeat the position or play play
D6 yeah it's hard to say
what do you guys think I'm hoping he
plays on I'm hoping he plays and we play
DC yeah he'll be more fun even it comes
even if it comes with a little bit of
risk
but I guess he can always like check on
F6 even later let's say if white plays
D6 here and black pushes his Pawn to A3
now you can still probably give a check
on F6 with a knight and go back to E8 so
Magnus always seems to have this option
unless the black king can go through it
exactly I was just thinking what happens
if the King goes Rogue this way yeah I
mean it does look a bit risky because
the king looks a little bit but if you
start running you can exactly you're
active yeah maybe Knight to C7 now
hitting this rook and if the Rook moves
perhaps you can grab uh take on F7 and
the Knight is actually sort of Trapped
maybe I get this guy but it's not enough
right I could take upon with check yeah
move King F1
and this guy might be trapped oh wow he
is trapped
oh unless there's some
tactics
you're always tricky David I'm a
trickster attacking this pawn and if you
take my knight I will give you a check
and I will push my Pawn
stop the pawn on D7 okay this is a
fantasy variation for sure it's not
realistic it's gonna happen yeah but
this is the type of thing that might be
going through magnus's mind right I mean
we know how good he is at calculation
and even though that variation was
nearly 10 moves long
he will be looking that deep I think he
will be trying to work out the uh
nuances I mean he has over an hour and
they've already made 28 moves he might
as well look for these types of lines
but I think if Magnus is going to check
with a knife probably young will not go
to H6 it's looks a bit risky probably
just go back with the King to jet black
yeah if black runs forward it's playing
with fire always does Magnus have any
other moves and Ponto D6 here because
he's uh he's thinking yeah I mean the
other move you mentioned to bring in the
night across to attack the Black Brook
um you mentioned this in a different
scenario but I'm not sure whether this
would work out too well for white
because the pin is probably annoying you
yeah then you can go forward with your
own Pawn now no longer you can push
forward because this Pawn just gets
doubled up yeah
yes you always have to control and
defend your own Pawn so yeah that's a
very instructive um
resource for black yeah so it looks like
either this one or a nut or what near my
arrows yeah and uh people on Twitter are
saying they believe that Magnus will
play the porn move D6 they have faith
that Magnus will play for a win on his
birthday too I think he's gonna at least
press for a couple more moves and as
Ariana said he's got it in his back
pocket if he needs like Last Resort he
can start giving some tracks and force a
draw there's no need to rush so it's not
dangerous for him it's not yeah it's
it's not dangerous because he can always
check with a knight and go back if he
feels the danger
that being said Magnus is uh has always
been the player that's if there is any
single chance to to play on and play for
a win he goes for it exactly he doesn't
want to take the draw he has such a such
a fighting Spirit even if there's just a
five percent chance the opponent might
go wrong yeah you might as well play
right and uh Magnus yeah he's done that
against me countless times so it would
actually be a little worrying if Magnus
you know doesn't push on a little bit
more
it would show that maybe his confidence
isn't as high as it usually is
um against mere mortals against kind of
run of the mildriums maybe not against
the pony actually uh against everyone
else I think he would play on instantly
he wouldn't even doubt himself he would
take some risks yeah he has I do think
that he has to try something against
Napoleon he has to put him a little bit
on edge that's been his strategy so far
you know make nipponichi think put him
under pressure and uh he knows that
napoleoni has actually played prepared
this opening and if he were just to
agree a draw just like that it would be
a moral victory for him and bearing in
mind that napony actually has the white
pieces tomorrow and it would be she's
turned to put Magnus under the
microscope I do think that Magnus has to
try here I I like this idea of pushing
forward with the pawn I think it seems
like it's the only shot left because
um otherwise you're just wasting time
right this is a race it might lead to
some long variations like the one we
showed but then again it would force
them actually to burn some energy
calculating these Force variations as
well
if there's no risk involved then why not
maybe let's look at that variation again
with with Pawn to D6 yeah so the pawn so
that's that's the way to play on yeah if
Magnus does want to win okay give a
check yeah he's dropped back with his
Knight maybe he'll repeat the position
once and then play on he does give check
the black king is going to March forward
and this will be the Moment of Truth
okay he goes and repeats the position
yeah
you always repeat the position once
that's that's the Russian strategy you
play with your opponents of feelings you
say draw no no draw Feud I wouldn't even
hesitate I would have repeated one
but anyway it's a it's a good strategy
to just show I'm the boss yeah I I'm I'm
the one who decides if I want to try so
this doesn't necessarily mean anything
not yet no it will depend on the next
move or two
um I like to repeat and then make eye
contact with my opponent as I play for a
win as I refuse to draw nice Mind Games
I've learned a lot from sitting next to
David how much is it so it's also about
playing the person eye contact oh I
would be so scarative
evil eyes all right well when napi comes
back now there is
well he is coming back right now there's
no doubt what he's going to play is it
either way the king one square forwards
definitely okay he won't even hesitate
here I would fall off my chair if he
played something else
you're still in your chair Ivanka so now
the question arises okay he plays for a
win Magnus Carl's in place wow where
when he continues the game all right
what does this mean what are we looking
at right now it means that the Norwegian
uh Rainey world champion he's ambitious
cool caged that black king so sometimes
maybe later down the line that black
king might be caught in what we call a
mating net
the black king won't be able to escape
it also cuts out some lines where we saw
the black king running out into the open
that being said it does take a move out
from the race to secure the position of
that white knight so now black can push
his Pawn forward and Magnus has to be
slightly careful of this black porn
running oh we have to look we like it
happens what happens if that pawn runs
actually drivanca's variation becomes
much more irrelevant now after white
played upon to G5 let's say if it was
white to move now then through Europe to
Seattle would be so deadly yeah uh
because you they're not on F6 is secured
and then if you get the Rook to C7 you
take that phone F7 is going to be mate
yeah for example Black's one square away
from yeah making a queen but it's too
late it's all about that past Bond
that's uh that's gonna stop stop white
from activating his Rook yeah and that's
why probably black just has to push
right
um so after white has pushed this Pawn
forward uh kind of sealing the black
king within its cage if black doesn't
push it's going to end up in Checkmate
so
um Black's Pawn
this is automatic almost firing up on
the action the question is if Magnus
let's say if Jan pushes his Pawn now to
H3 Magnus can still repeat the position
but do you do you guys think he has a
another idea
uh what to say okay I see something
pretty cool actually let's say if if
white plays Rook C1 after A3 mm-hmm
and then uh black pushes black pushes
then take on F7 wow okay this looks like
very cool uh sacrifice in the rook and
if black takes Rook to C7
and it looks like Checkmate but the
Black Knight can go to D7 sacrificing
itself and then white takes the Rook
black plays King to f8 and then actually
it ends in the draw
it will be more more cool more cool way
to draw that Knight takes H7 it's a bit
of a windmill right it just goes round
and round it has to take a Perpetual
because otherwise black will Queen and
you can show David if the black king
goes to h8 yeah then the Arabic mates
Ivanka you know your mates
yeah top players do right you know those
names I actually didn't know but I just
heard it on the show
you learn something new every day I
guess nice to be here I didn't know
there were any other checkmates apart
from just the word Checkmate until I met
your Banker
um yeah so in the current position we're
expecting Napoleon actually to push this
Pawn forward because that's his main
source of counter play you can't be too
slow you can't wait
potentially you could push your Pawn
forward here
and just ask white a question of what to
do with this Pawn which does support the
White Knight
but uh I guess white will just back up
his Pawn here protect him you could also
give a check right
you could also okay yeah maybe give a
check with the white knight now and then
if the black king drops back maybe you
could consider taking this ball
okay interesting and that would have
changed the position slightly
so yeah I'm trying to look for options
for Napoleon actually after black pushes
forward
or instead of black pushing forward but
I'm pretty sure we'll see this happen on
the board shortly and there we go after
three minutes does push his Pawn now the
now the big question comes okay if minus
is gonna go for a draw we will we
haven't seen anything better but what
could Magnus have up a sleeve in this
particular position I mean is it to
trade works and just kind of
make a beeline trade Works how um
yeah
there could be that one as well also
dropping the Rope back but I like this
one let's try this back
hoping that after a trade that
run with the Knights oh yeah what run
with the night or going back towards
yeah head back or maybe just uh initiate
another race because after all the
Knight is in a cage this Black Knight is
trapped this black king is also trapped
but then again White's Rook is good it's
up in the corner it's Amir bystander a
mere passenger
you know this is why we talk about
Brooks being behind past bonds this Rook
supports uh the black pawn and White's
Rook is it can never move because if it
does black will make a new Queen so yeah
this is a really weird scenario actually
with blacks knight and king traft but
then White's Rook also paralyzed if you
would bin time to bring the king over to
a question yeah but yeah I mean it takes
takes too much time I guess in the
meantime maybe black can what is black
doing there
maybe black and H6 first page four and
then take trading and then bring the
Knight out this way but
hmm
even if the knights come off it's not
clear I think black isn't risking too
much to be honest but yeah it doesn't
seem like because the Palm A2 is also so
strong yeah
I mean with a rook like this one stuck
in the corner not being able to do
anything I don't think white can ever
try to win this game so I would be very
surprised if Magnus tried to trade Rooks
other way yeah so moving The Rook up the
board
another mate it's called The Hook mate
the hook mate okay so okay so let's say
it is yeah so say black uh tries doesn't
swap off works just moves The Rook off
the ball yeah and then I just make make
a random move for white and then move
the Black Knight out of the way I just
wanted to highlight this pattern because
as soon as you're aware of the patterns
then you can really spot the checkmating
ideas and then the root can move to the
G8 square and this would be the hook
mate because it's caught in a hook okay
you know your mates
just the names Ivanka wrote a book right
The Mating Game experts
okay so this is the current position and
Magnus just thinking whether he can
continue taking risk continue pushing
for the win I really like that Rook C1
Rook C1 move if you want to make a draw
just make it in a in a fun way a
beautiful way just the one other
variation if black plays A2 here after
Rook C1 Rook takes F7 so we saw that
King takes F7 is a joy if black plays
King h8 instead I you can maybe just
play King G2 ah very nice
and then if black does make a new Queen
we take
still not clear but yeah King G7 and
then maybe Rook B8 yeah and white has
two pawns and a knight for one rook and
actually here the knights probably just
a monster just a beast yeah White's
gonna deliver some nasty checks where I
can never lose this white might even win
because these pawns are just powerful uh
this guy dropping off as well so okay
Magnus got some ideas in mind
um I'm hoping as well maybe for aryan's
uh pretty pattern there or going for the
draw but
um if Magnus can't find a way to press
and kind of put some pressure on without
taking risks then he'll just give
another night check and repeat
well he is in deep thought now Magnus
Carlsen it's going to be very
interesting to see what his next move is
while he's thinking let's take a look at
your selfies
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right so we're just setting up the
position here assignment this was
magnus's last Jana pongyachi's last move
what do you think about the situation
there now I'm well I think Magnus is
trying everything he can
um but he realizes at some point he's
gonna have to take the draw there's only
so much you can do
obviously he's really resilient to take
that draw he's got the white pieces he
had this game plan I'm sure today try
everything make it a long game but uh
Black's basically played a perfect game
of chess
um I found it quite interesting actually
I I said in a tweet that no one really
expected this opening from Yan but there
was Lawrence Trent
um who is I think visiting the studio at
some point in the future yeah and he
said that he had all the way up to move
23 Rook D3 in his notes so uh uh some
people have seen this before obviously
done their homework but we didn't expect
it and uh in the studio uh but I I don't
really see now how Magnus can keep the
game going to this Pawn is so strong
it's two squares away from coming down
and with the Rook combining with it
Magnus is going to have to I feel uh
take the draw even now by moving the
Knight backwards and forwards this is
one possibility or by trying this I like
the flashy way of doing it'd be nice to
see a bit of a bit of Glamor on the
board with some Rook coming in uh but of
course I I don't know if I'd be brave
enough to play this move in the game
because even though you're pretty
confident to draw if you've
miscalculated and you end up losing this
you you would just really not have a
great birthday would you so so I think I
think move the Knight backwards and
forwards here is is very likely to occur
and just take the draw he's tried
everything he can sometimes you just
gotta yeah just well that's it you know
yeah go and enjoy your birthday dinner
or something instead and after I have to
say it's interesting coming to the
physical the actual chess board I'm
standing now where Ariana palmyachi is
sitting and I can feel that just my
black ink it's very safe do you think
Young is feeling very confident and safe
where he's sitting right now I think
he'll be very confident he's just he's
managed to calculate everything
incredibly well I think you can see that
in his body language very hard to tell
Jana he's walking around
um I mean often the king's stuck in that
position it could be in a lot of danger
but because he's got this counter play
this Pawn is just so strong it's such a
strong port and his whole idea of
pushing it earlier on was was just a
very good idea so what do you feel I I
know you're a big kind of over-the-board
chest Simon how do you feel about game
four now again the player is deep in
opening preparations you know way into
move 20s i i in some ways I think it's
to be expected I mean these two have got
as as you were discussing the best
preparation are using top computers
they're using top teams they've got
access to special computers they've got
massive memory banks they've got massive
you know their seconds of memories
you're going to expect in this match the
margins to be so small I personally find
that more exciting because this it's not
a one-way competition it's the smallest
of smallest of things will make that
difference to who the world champion is
going to be and I've always fought this
world championships is going to be a
very very close Affair I think I was
going to go 55 in magnus's in magnus's
favor uh before the match and
um it does look so far like it it
probably is going to be very closer
close fit certainly is so far and it
could be close to another drug in game
four and this game you did mention this
move maybe that's what we're hoping for
a little bit flashy yeah a bit flashy is
good so what other options if we look at
this uh physical board what other
options are we looking at I think now I
think the simplest is just to move the
Knight give the check so you move the
Knight there you attack the king the
black king really has to move you can't
give up your Rook for it and wherever it
goes we just move the Knight back and we
just repeat the position three times and
I think someone mentioned actually we
had a Max
we don't do that in England we don't
make hers
Max the Norwegian word for beer oh I
should know that yeah yeah
definitely but I think he was one of the
people who said about this this freefold
repetition he was very involved with the
mathematical side of that but I expect
that will occur I don't know if anyone
if David's anyone else can you know
Ivanka tarry if you can find another
option I don't know but I just don't see
how Magnus can play on here I just think
it has come to a point where you just
got to shake hands yeah yeah and if it
is a quite Quick Draw then we can head
down to good night celebrate your
birthday and have a few hours Simon love
it yes hurry up guys come on move so
yeah what are we seeing on the board
David are there any other possibilities
we're wearing this Carlson so Magnus
doesn't have to go for the draw
immediately this idea that Simon
mentioned with the night checks it would
still exist maybe on the next move so he
might defer And Delay that decision
another move or two but the longer he
delays it the more risk is involved so I
think Simon is probably correct
um I would be slightly tempted to just
play on maybe just push the kill white
king forward one square maybe push a
pawn maybe block this black porn with
the Rook but either way I think a draw
is quite likely at the stage all right
yeah I've been thinking now for
11 minutes Magnus Carlton is he
desperately David trying to find
something else to do yes I think he's
probably spotted aryan's uh nice pretty
idea there by bringing the white Rook
across he knows that ends in a draw he
knows that
um he knows he does have a backup plan
he does have some Last Resorts to to go
to if he needs
uh if kind of things start turning
against him he knows he always has these
night checks
still no risk right now but uh the
longer he thinks I think the more likely
it is that he will come to the
conclusion there's nothing else to do
here despite the computer giving 0.2
this doesn't feel like anything at all
this feels like uh pretty level position
Aryan any new ideas I was thinking about
another funny idea it was very similar
to the other one king to G2 as you said
it's good new ideas are always fun and
then let's say black pushes the pawn A2
and now we're Rook C1 okay so actually
probably even cooler so this doesn't
work I think because oh oh yeah you can
sacrifice with the queen Queen on F6 yes
yeah okay I went too far there this is
flashy yeah you can show that I was
thinking Rook takes F7 here if the it's
a black king where to go to h8 you can
take the take the queen that would be
good for good for white because you get
an end game where you have two pawns a
knight for that for the rook and then
later you can play Rook to B8 yeah but
this doesn't work because black can just
take the Rook yep so uh in this position
after Brook takes check King takes Rook
C7 and uh yeah here I went to fire
bricks other Knight D7 Rook takes D7
King f8
and it might take stage seven I was I
cannot you cannot give a check again on
F6 because black can just take with the
queen yeah suddenly black has this new
Queen on the board which is a nice
tricky piece and at the very end it does
a good job yeah she does a great
defensive job actually protecting her
King from the far corner and then at the
very end black would emerge with two
extra Rooks so
um yep so this idea of bringing the Rook
across and kind of sacrificing and
opening up the black king it only works
now
um it wouldn't work on the next move I
was actually thinking if you move
forward with the King after the black
pushers are born you could at least
maybe Retreat your Rook
to double up on this Pawn forcing black
to put both of his Rooks behind to
defend I'm not sure what this actually
gains actually jovanka just uh just show
me that variation
we were just discussing that yeah we
didn't quite we didn't quite see
anything any form of progress for white
yeah exactly that's the problem you get
this position but it's very hard to do
anything with a with deeper like every
single time you know you try to push the
pawn in the middle of the board the
Knight is release yeah and uh the Black
Knight jumps out yeah
nasty night check ideas
I was yeah it's weird seeing this
situation where white Rooks are tied
down against this Pawn but also
blackstrokes are also tied down against
this Pawn I was wondering whether you
could kind of inch forward like push
your Pawn one square and next move bring
your king forward then maybe bring It
Forward another Square then push your
pawn and caterpillar approach creepy
crawly yeah but even like Spider-Man
exactly inch by inch but the problem is
maybe black will just push a pawn and
after a trade maybe he can actually try
and make some progression that's a
strong move of Knight H7 just trading
off the annoying Knight on F6 yeah and
once that happens I think white is the
only one who is in danger here probably
still a draw but uh due to the strength
of this powerful Pawn tying down the
whole white Rook
black will never ever lose this one so
not much to gain for uh from that
variation if Magnus wants to play on
moving his King forward
I was also slightly wondering whether
maybe okay if we do move the king
forward whether you could push the Rook
up now but again if if black just slides
across and keeps the tension
with the Rooks
a set of one a set of Trades would not
help white because if you compare the
remaining Rooks whites is passive blacks
is active black can use all of these
squares White's Rook is completely stuck
it's what to do with this pawn and uh
yeah right now Magnus struggling to come
up with ideas yeah I think he's either
gonna go for a 98 check or or Rook C1
it's one of those I check we'll bring
the Rook across but that's gonna lead to
a draw it's very hard for him to find
anything because upon A3 is so strong
yeah yeah Simon mentioned this it's all
about this guy right now so it does look
like this game is going to finish in a
draw and uh nasos on Twitter says that
machines are memorized machine opening
moves take away the real beauty of the
game that had Fisher on mind when he
left left a visual chess and it's
certainly an accusation that we've kind
of seen from the media and we've seen
from a lot of people saying that hey
this is just killing Jess do you agree
with this or do you think that you know
the fact that uh the player with the
black pieces will have a moral Advantage
a psychological advantage actually adds
a new layer to the game
um yeah I think chess is so vast it's so
rich that there's still plenty to
explore we don't know I mean we're just
touching the surface still now and okay
at this very kind of heightened level at
this extreme level where they're also
good and they don't really want to take
risks and it's a one-on-one battle then
maybe having computers does take some of
the Intrigue out but I mean we've been
playing tournaments I mean the grand
Swiss recently so many decisive games so
many new ideas all the time you can
still fight
computers have taught us that anything's
possible all these openings which in the
past were kind of deemed dubious now
they're viable and
um
I think if we embrace the computers then
there's still a lot to learn and a lot
to enjoy yeah yeah I think we can't get
too cynical yet and say Jess is dead
we've been saying that for 30 years but
uh it's not true yet how many possible
moves again after two moves on the
chessboard after Black's first move
there's 400 different positions and I
think that's already in the millions
after Black's second move yeah wow maybe
several Millions exactly it's extremely
deep this game so it's probably not
going to be sold even by computers and
that's going to be that exactly I don't
think so I mean even if computers solve
it we can't memorize it all right
exactly I know that sudden openings have
been refuted but the actual way to
refute this particular these openings
are so complex and such a treacherous
tight right that's impossible for humans
to kind of gauge how to do it so I think
I agree you know this if you Embrace
computers like Davis says it adds a new
layer to the game and for me I find it
very fascinating how only these players
going to outwit each other when they
have super computers at their disposal
and we saw Magnus employ a really rare
line it wasn't the Top Choice you know
it wasn't the necessarily the main line
but nepo nepen upon me actually got into
his head and predicted this I mean
that's incredible about that that is
going to psych magnus's team out so I
can't wait to see how they're going to
react tomorrow that's it we can blame
computer preparation but in the end it's
a human battle one-on-one and nipomyachi
he just understood that maybe Magnus
would want this kind of rare line maybe
this is magnus's type of position so he
predicted it and it's still that it's
still that human battle
um once you scratch beneath the surface
what what team do you think has been the
winner so far uh Ariana
um it's it's hard to say because Magnus
with the black bits is he kind of I
would say one won the opening battles uh
he was the one that surprised Dion Dion
was the first one that started to take
but today we just have to say Jan was so
impressive we did with his opening like
all the 26 moves uh he just knew and
remembered so deep but so today he's the
winner in the in the opening but I
wouldn't say like in the other other
games it's been pretty even so far that
being said the today's game was a bit
dry but those three other games were
quite fighting
um so yeah I mean in 14 games we
sometimes we have games like this where
not much happens and it just ends in a
draw but uh so many rounds to go and I'm
sure we will see blood yeah I was
thinking a new scoring system you know
like boxing you know how they rate
um punches and the amount of hits maybe
they should have a new scoring system
when it comes to time breaks you know
you have a fun a panel of Judges who won
the opening
that's very true yeah that's why I
always like math in school we've been
talking about math with Mark server
today because there was no teacher could
ever give me the wrong grade I felt like
you know we know what the answer is so I
will always get the correct grade how
are you in math Aryan so I asked Simon
the question are all chess players great
at math David and Ivanka previously told
me they'd well that big of math fans in
school how about you actually me neither
it's interesting that most people
outside from Chester I think that chess
players are like Geniuses when it comes
to math they are so so good at it but I
just had like normal grades I feel like
you if you want to become very good at
math you have to spend a lot of time on
it and I didn't really do that live chat
so maybe yeah so I wouldn't say like you
you're like good at math because you're
a good champion where you'd have to
spend time on it like everything else
yeah so there's always the question of
sort of what approach you have to the
game if it is the scientific which I
guess would be the the great
mathematicians like my example or the
artistic maybe or or more the the
competitive or the sports aspect which
one would you prefer
the competitive or the the so what do
you have you have scientific artistic
and sports right if you consider chess
to be a sport Science or Arts oh that's
a good question
I would say sports yeah yeah the
competitiveness yeah I feel it's really
competitive yeah yeah you know it
reminds me of a conversation I had with
uh renowned trainer Mark deboretsky and
he was talking about the British School
of Chess and he said you know the
British school with chess used to be
like mathematicians scientists all
working everything out perfectly and
then the street fighters came along
and these are the sporting aspects you
know they didn't care whether they
played ugly chess it was just all about
winning and posing the most practical
problems yeah so risk-taking exciting
tricking that's what we do now in
England
isn't that what Magnus is kind of known
for too though like the sports approach
yeah he's Universal though Magnus I mean
he's artistic when he can be he loves
looking for these pretty moves these
nice patterns
um definitely the sporty approach I mean
for him it's all about the result and
that shows a sportsman but he can't be
scientific when he needs to be as well
and that's what we've seen in his world
championship matches I think he's maybe
less comfortable when it becomes purely
a science when it's all about crunching
the numbers where it's all about kind of
working out the details of all these
openings he prefers when it's just a
hand-to-hand fight but
yep he's a universal player maybe more
than any other so yeah then
that's a tough one okay he seems like a
very competitive guy right he's very
emotional it feels like he would fall
under the sports category I would
definitely say he's the he falls under
the sport category because Jan he if you
see his games he actually makes a lot of
objective mistakes but he plays with
speed and uh he just like yeah real real
sportsman does everything for the for
the result and it and it pays off
um maintenance plays much more accurate
just chest and yarn but the yarn
he's like play some psychological games
plays very fast and uh yeah just kind of
provokes his opponent to make make
mistakes and sometimes he gets very bad
positions but he's
fighting so well and he's setting up
dirty tricks that it it works for him
exactly actually he played Jan
um just recently in OHS a couple of
months ago and I know you beat him there
in the classical well not right do you
think it was because maybe he was
reverting to those tricks you mentioned
and uh yeah a little bit out of hand for
him or yeah I think he probably
underestimated me a bit he was white
against me and he was probably thinking
that it's gonna be an easy game but you
showed him who's boss yeah we can say
that I showed him who was the boss no he
played very aggressive from the start
and went went all out but at some point
he played some inaccurate moves and I
got the initiative
and then he was actually looking very
confidently and he was walking playing
fast but I knew Yan and I know that he
usually does that even when he has a bad
position so I was just like trying to
not get affected by his uh psychological
tricks yeah and I managed to keep calm
and won a great game do you actually
nowadays also or maybe always been like
that you have to actually prepare for
the type of person you're facing as well
knowing you know what they will do if
they feel they have a bad position or a
good position so that you're not psyched
out yeah yes it's kind of uh I mean in
general you should just try to focus on
the board and not get affected by by how
your opponent behaves but uh the top
players you kind of seeing them so many
times you know how they usually usually
behave so I was like kind of I've seen
Jan do it do it so many times I was
aware of it and that maybe half the bit
to not get slacked out yeah do you feel
he's evolved a bit slightly young over
the last year I mean obviously he still
occasionally has those types of games
where he
maybe placed too much on the
psychological factor and forgets the
chest but to me in the candidates
tournament the second half and the match
so far here it feels like he's added
this kind of solid layer where he's
become more grounded he can control his
emotions and he became he became much
more stable in the last five years where
he made this jump from 2700 to almost
2800 he has a much more he has much less
of those off days where he uh yeah
gets like affected but by what happened
the game before
so that that has definitely been very
important for him so Magnus can't rely
on Jan having an update anymore right
I mean in the past he would have
expected Yan to have one or two bad days
but now the way he's playing if he loses
one game we will that will be the big
question I think John has always been
pretty bad at dealing with losses so
it's going to be the critical test if
you lose the game right and it's great
at bouncing back but Jan the opposite
right yeah yeah exactly yeah Magnus in
fact said you can hit him in the face
and he will just pick himself up and
continue and he considered that Jan's
biggest weakness was the fact that he
couldn't he would just turn to collapse
um but having said that you know we are
going to see that uh in action in this
once the players start exchanging
punches well I do love that that story
from 2016 told by esplan Augustine when
Magnus lost the game to Sergey karyakin
and the whole team went to a restaurant
and they figured out let's order some
drinks and I guess I got quite uh fun
that evening and Magnus did bounce back
two games later with a win so sometimes
the end Magnus is actually told stories
like that before right after a loss I
think during Blitz and Rapid 2012 yeah
he went to his room and got some vodka I
think he just drank everything from the
minibar came back won eight games in a
row wow that was in World Blitz
championship in 2012. wow I mean have
you guys tried it is it something that
would work it doesn't work for the
majority
of people I have to say no it doesn't
work it's not recommended that's
certainly not recommended I would
recommend the routine not the alcohol of
course but breaking your routine is
normally a good thing if you're in bad
form switch things up just do something
different whether it's going for a run
whether it's going to a new place for
dinner having new food or
um or meeting up with new friends or
watching a movie or something but don't
stay in your routine if you're in bad
form if you continue on in your routine
you'll stay in that form ah likewise if
you're in good form never break a
routine don't do anything differently
because that will trick your mind into
thinking that
um you know the tension is over yeah
yeah you need if you're playing well
maintain the maintain the routine if
you're playing badly do anything to
change it up okay I think that's the tip
anyway all right and uh yeah no alcohol
that's not what we recommend here on the
show we don't recommend that at all do
you think for for miners uh because all
eyes are on him pressure is extremely
big like in the world rapid and Blitz
you know people are expecting him to win
and it's a lot of pressure maybe when he
starts losing a few games so you know
again not you know advising for the
alcohol but that is stuff he needs to do
to just forget about the pressure and
forget about everything well with minus
he's so used to this pressure he's been
like number one for for 10 years and
played played these matches so he's just
I think he deals with it pretty well
but uh just being able for him to play
some sports on the on the rest day and
uh get his Minds somewhere else I think
it's very nice way to to relax
he does have a lot of experience now
right with the world championship
matches how to spend the rest days even
what to do if it goes badly for a game
or two yeah he'll have plans in place as
well like obviously he wants to play
football on the rest days and chill but
if that's not working for him then I'm
sure he has other ideas of what he can
do how to spend the time and
uh
it's all about experience for him
sometimes especially in the world
championship matches I think more than
any other time he does talk about the
pressure he does mention that maybe it
stops him from taking risks that's why
we've seen 17 games in World
Championship matches drawn in a row
because I think it's the risk that's the
one place I mean it doesn't force him to
make mistakes it's just it stops him
from taking risk
at some point in this match he will
maybe take a risk but
four games in it's it does feel like
he's still within himself he's still
within his shell but I have to say one
thing that we kind of forgetting a
little bit is that he is playing some
exceedingly well prepared opponents You
Know karaoke and Carolina
they've been preparing for him for
months and you know I do know that
Carolina was also using neural
network-based engines but they were very
much in their infancy and now so
um not sergeyanna pomniacci has amassed
a whole team who knows how much money
has been spent in collecting the
resources so that he can prepare against
Magnus there's rumors that Sega karakin
used one million dollars
for in his preparations against Magnus
you know and
I mean I don't know whether that's true
or not but I'm assuming that it's a
significant amount of money that Jana
Pony actually he has supercomputers at
his disposal and again he has a team you
know I'm for sure there's going to be a
performance uh psychologist in there
just trying to get into the minds of
Magnus and just try to predict exactly
what he's playing so I think that
there's going to be draws I do think
that with the style of both these
players
that I do think there will be there will
be at some point there has to be at some
point a decisive game it really feels
like it yeah all right well Magnus
thinking for 30 minutes and I understood
on you guys there's not many options for
him no actually stockfish there we do
see three suggestions from the computer
and all of them are roughly equal the
top suggestion by stockfish is just
giving a night check but the night came
from there a few turns ago I think the
plus 0.2 is just the computer being
slightly too optimistic it just means
it's completely level and the other
moves just pushing a pawn for whites
pushing Harry the h-born or just pushing
the king forward those would likely lead
to draws anyway over the next few turns
so your flashy move is not on the
stockfish top three Raider
not yet they are surprising that Rook C1
is not there but it might be the fourth
choice I mean probably Rook C1 is 0.0 as
well so King G2
is there anything that Magnus could be
thinking about like I've seen some
suggestions on Twitter for instance
maybe swapping off a set of Rooks I mean
we touched upon this idea
which direction up or down both are
actually um so let's try the one that's
uh where the Rook moves down okay and uh
here black is pretty much obliged to
trade if you move away then suddenly the
Black Horn drops and once that pawn
drops all of Black's play uh dissipates
disappears so um okay trade and now I
want to lock in the white rook and keep
you stuck on this Square I'm not sure I
need to actually as black but uh it
looks pretty it's just forcing this Rook
uh into this cage and I guess the white
King has to March forward at some point
maybe you want to bring it across to try
and eventually Round Up This Pawn yeah
this would
allow black to challenge this stronghold
and if we do see a pawn trade on this
side of the board the question is
whether black trades Knights or not I'm
not 100 sure
um if the knights do disappear from the
board it does take quite a long time to
start running with the King and uh in
the meantime black at some point will
just be able to
just put the Rook on a square where it
will light up some pawns maybe that's
the wrong Square for the white king but
either way Black's Brook will just sit
on a very active square and
I don't know it feels to me as if
White's risking stuff King is such a
slow piece you know I mean if you could
magically magically transport the king
you know all the way over to the C6
Square it'd be awesome but uh it's just
going to take a long time to get there
right we'll take an age together yeah
The Rook is so stuck on A1 yeah it takes
so many moves to get it to a normal
Square too risky yeah it feels like
white is the one that that's risking and
black can maybe bring his King to D6 or
play F6 yep black and bring the king
over or push upon and create a passport
of his own as soon as the white king
goes over then horns will start to drop
and uh another suggestion that I've seen
on Twitter is actually okay so what
happens if the white Rook just decides
to go Pawn hunting
um this is quite an interesting question
but you do have to deal with this huge
Pawn that's sitting on the A3 square
that means this would terrify The Living
Daylights out of me yeah unfortunately
here you might be one move too slow as
white right because the pawn can step
forward and after important why it's a
pulling up and white kind of threatens
to go across actually to block this
black rook's connection with its Pawn
but black now could just step across and
this is coming next move no matter what
and this will eliminate the white rook
and force the black pawn through to
Glory so
I think this will cost quite a rook for
example if the king steps forward the
Black Brook will come down and this guy
trapped if you take of course a new
Queen appears on the board so
nice idea that I've just maybe just one
move too slow because Black's Pawn is
too strong and if that's too slow
okay let's maybe revisit this king move
I think mayonnaise is basically like
considering every move in the position
is just really want to keep the game
going so yeah so you said King G2 yeah
if the pawn steps forward I want to
maybe try this side here again pushing
forward with the Rook oh yes what if uh
black plays like Rook A7 okay okay seven
can't go for it now can I oh here he
comes okay it's a night check yeah this
one doesn't look like it's leading
anywhere either so
um night check are we about to see a
draw if the black king goes back Magnus
leaving the board that he will probably
just drop the Knight back with a check
and we might well see a repetition now
position repeating itself
you will be back quite soon but why
would minus leave the board if if he was
if he's thinking to repeat I mean maybe
he knows Yan will take a couple of
minutes to come back anyway maybe maybe
spent 30 minutes needing the bathroom
and he needed to I was gonna suggest
that you know he spent half an hour
sitting down and often you know when
you've spent so long just calculating
you need the bathroom you need just to
kind of clear your head yeah maybe he
goes to the bathroom and some new ideas
yeah comes to his mind yes I haven't see
you guys maybe once in a while it can
happen but usually not like especially
when you've been sitting at the board
for 30 minutes you've seen uh all the
ideas yeah have you ever happened to me
twice like once being in the bathroom
and I was just sitting there thinking
I'm dead lost I'm about to resign and
then I thought okay there must be one
last trick and then suddenly I thought
oh wait maybe I'm winning it's such a
good feeling I know yeah then you're
kind of like celebrating in the bathroom
yes I feel like such a creeping though
you're like screaming in the bathroom
from happiness when I came back I looked
at the board I was like oh I got the
position wrong in my head that's a cold
shower yeah I mean I wasn't losing at
least one thing that did happen to me
while I was uh so my opinion on myself
we just made 40 moves
and I thought okay I've survived and
then I realized I'm winning and then
bonds from Yarn yeah forced move uh he
has to move his King back and so the
question now reminders will he move his
Knight back again yeah there he goes
here he comes
anchor
Magnus is it an immediately a draw if
Magnus now goes back or do they need to
do it yet because they moved importance
in between your eyes
body language he's coming back with a
knight that doesn't necessarily mean
he's going to force the draw leaving
again and away again
but this will be the moment if he brings
his Knight forward this position has
risen twice now if he brings his Knight
forward that'll be the second time that
position has happened on the board as
well but if he brings this Knight
forward I think we'll see the draw
because why don't you leave the board
again and that's what happened I'm
laughing at that you know Magnus comes
in makes a move leaves Jan makes makes a
move leaves
maybe he was halfway through some snacks
all right Magnus is coming back to the
board
what will he do okay I have a feeling
that he's going to play on yeah do you
yeah otherwise why leave the board right
yeah maybe because he's had he's trying
to send a message to Jan about leaving
the board
I'm hoping he plays on as well because
my prediction previously was 42 moves
Magnus plays on at least until the time
control just throw his body language it
feels like he's going to play on but I
could be wrong let's see
I mean you you probably know this body
language more than most uh Aryan
and I'd be inclined to agree although
okay he's paused so it's really hard to
call here whether he's going to play on
or not so do you think he's made his
decision yet or is he I think not yet
he's he's repeated once just to show he
has the draw in hand still if he needs
it but maybe we'll see him indulge in
another 10 minute think
at least for a few minutes
I don't think he's risking much if he
just does move his king or moves upon
because he still has this drawing idea
on the next turn
that's uh okay Moment of Truth Magnus
stop teasing us
yeah if you place on I think he goes
like King G2 maybe just improve his King
position yeah and then after A2 maybe
then repeat that he said
well
I to play on here minus I mean he has
spent now a lot of time he is down to 30
minutes on his clock he needs to reach
move 40 to get another hour on the clock
could that be an issue for him the clock
time yeah because has a lot of time and
maybe it's a little bit complicated
going forwards then yeah I mean if you
do start taking some big risks then it
will become very Concrete where you need
to calculate and you want extra time on
the clock but
right now it's manageable it's uh it's
not too drastic
okay I'm trying to think what's going on
in his mind because okay making some
facial expression there as well as the
chest moves he's probably just thinking
okay with white there is this kind of
moral burden to play on
to kind of bail out at the first chance
I don't know how I have a feeling he's
going to take the draw yeah I mean
should we put on a bat
there is there is one variation that we
didn't really look at which is an option
Pawn to H4 okay let's try so this is
potentially what Magnus is considering
as well or something he's looked at
pushing forward yeah pushed upon to H4
black pushes his Pawn that's that's
logical and then push the push the pawn
to H5 okay so trying to really keep yeah
yeah really trying to catch the black
king So if let's say if black would play
like Rook to B3 now trying to get the
Rook to B1 and make a queen then you can
play Pawn to H6 King to h8 and here you
have a good move uh King to G2
and let's say black plays Rook to B1 now
and here you can sacrifice your roof you
can take the pawn A2 black takes the
rook and then you can play Rook to E8
and this is a beautiful position here we
see actually maybe black can sacrifice
both of user okay yeah maybe one this is
actually really cool right very nice
stalemate suddenly for example Black's
King is trapped actually uh and Black's
Knight cannot move so maybe black can
hope to give up both Rooks and suddenly
earlier we saw wiping a rook up and
almost winning but now wait uh sorry
wiping a rook down and almost winning
now White's a rook up and not winning
because the trickster strikes again
yeah Black's king is not getting mated
it's getting stalemated yeah and yeah
the question is is if the white king can
run away but anyway this variation looks
a bit dangerous for for yarn so after H5
one to H5 if you go a few moves back it
looks logical if black takes that bomb
to get some air for for the king Take
the pawn white takes for the knights and
here is very important to not go up with
the King because then there is this nice
fork with Knight F4 check picking up the
Rook
so black should go back with the King to
G8
and here still if Magnus wants a joy he
can repeat the position yeah yeah I was
also thinking I was also thinking that
maybe you can kind of kill the danger in
its infancy by just simply pushing your
Pawn to H5 yeah that's so this position
yeah luck yeah just kind of kill it
I don't want anything any checkmating
ideas so now white can never take one
person because the night drops and you
can only play once right first oh so
actually I didn't know that only on the
first move that uh black tries to bypass
your Pawn for example here if black
moves two squares forward you can take
it now as if it moves once
but if you wait for example if you give
a night check first and the King moves
you cannot take it now
um yeah
very uh important trick there to
remember one percent you can only
capture immediately okay and uh yeah
that would be a decent move as well just
blocking up White's Pawn pushes I think
the more time Magnus spends the more
likely is it to go for a draw because
let's say if he spends 10 minutes more
and has like 15 minutes left yeah then
maybe he feels he doesn't have so much
time
too risky to play on then it had no time
to calculate just in case you've missed
something but I do quite like this idea
of just uh pushing the pawn and seeing
whether nepomayachi is aware of this
kind of of the danger I'm just wondering
if there's risk involved if you push
this Pawn uh if after four steps forward
I mean possibly this one but you'd also
have to calculate what's happening after
this but then to rwanka's idea with 98
is maybe smart and then take the pollen
H6 even than okay maybe there are some
checkmates
wondering whether who's quick enough but
I think it's the same idea right yeah
just getting the king to the cage now
it's not still mate actually this gets
yeah this is a beautiful idea Rook takes
up okay it's yeah I'm going for
checkmate now it's no no longer still
mate black can't give up the Rooks
because this Pawn is free to move later
on
uh White would actually be winning here
Checkmate yeah so maybe he can get away
with this uh Magnus he can get away with
a few things either pushing this Pawn
forward maybe moving his King forward
but if he gets too low on the clock
we'll see a night check and a repetition
are you puzzled the miners Crossing is
uh thank you for so much time he's more
than 40 minutes down on the clock from
janaji now I'm kind of uncharacteristic
right uh this is the type of thing I do
but I never see the top players doing
kind of burning it's inspired by you
David oh sure I think corrupted by me
more likely been hanging out too much
with you
it's letting all my bad habits
indecisiveness but also winning games
yeah but look at my nose curls in here
he's just in deep thought you would have
thought that during that half hour break
that he took thinking that he sort of
would have made the plan going forward
yeah his his unsure because he sees that
he can make another move to play on but
then again what we talked about earlier
he has to make the Perpetual yeah let's
say one move later and then he doesn't
see the sense to let's say play the king
to G2 or upon to H4 and then black
pushes the pawn and then he has to give
the check anyway
yeah do you think he's finished
calculated he's just
doing making decision pretty much I mean
as Aryan mentioned uh I mean these top
players are so good so after 30 minutes
thinking a couple of moves ago he's
probably seen everything there is to see
he wouldn't be finding any new ideas
necessarily I I have an idea so I have
an idea and I and uh the quick run
through with the computer so the first
move is our arian's move to advance the
pawn okay and then here I'm just
thinking that maybe he might want to
kill the game and just uh also make play
my suggestion which was to push the pawn
yeah and then here
push the white Pawn in the center one
square wow okay yeah so I'm the big idea
is is that uh what if you do push the
black pawn to the A2 Square I should
mention the pawn cannot be taken because
there's a night check and uh this is a
fork yeah so this will cost black a rook
uh so you mentioned your anchor pushing
this guy forward yeah and then the white
work will now just drop down to the
second row okay some pressure on this
yes so the natural move is actually just
to
like to protect the pawn and then the
white idea is basically that uh the
White Knight is loose and the White
Knight can start harassing the pawn on
beatex okay so you can drop back maybe
at some point yeah go for this guy
um so if so first of all start with uh
maybe start with the pawn on pushing to
D7 okay once go away yeah and if the
Knight for example comes out now the
night is released now the White Knight
is released and can jump over yes
snacking on pawns there you go
interesting and again this tension
between all of the Rooks the black Rooks
they're defending this pawn and then the
white Rooks attacking the spawn it's
not clear whose Rooks are better but if
the white knight is better than the
Black Knight then maybe some chances for
Magnus
so so uh Hey so if anything we're
expecting either a draw immediately or
this Pawn push okay
okay if we if we see a push of that pawn
Magnus might well have some tricks up
his sleeve
but much time not much time anymore I
mean we had this position and Magnus had
around an hour on the clock
so he spent 30 minutes on this exact
position two moves ago it repeated
itself and then he spent 10 minutes on
this move
huge consumption you can see it on his
body language he is you know
some itching something is itching yeah I
think it's really unhappy to not be able
to put any pressure with with whites
just for yum to get such an easy game is
is pretty frustrating yeah
all right clock still thinking ticking
10 minutes now on this move minus curls
and will he go for the draw
or will he keep pushing that is the big
question
feels tense right now yeah I think world
championship matches are just especially
tense if this was an open tournament
Magnus would just make a decision he
would either make the draw immediately
or he'd push and
kind of trusted instincts but World
Championship matches it's not just the
moves it's not just the board it's the
psychology and he wants to yeah he wants
to tell Yan that he's not scared
it's a he'll take risks we'll put
pressure if he can
and uh
yeah I know I can't wait and I do have a
question from Bobo on Twitter who asks
us did Alpha zero games change the way
top chess players well top chess games
are played did players find any new
pattern in those games
yeah I think definitely uh Magnus
himself said that he probably felt his
strongest at the beginning of 2019 after
his match against Carolina
um and there he was playing lots of
ideas inspired by Alpha zero and Leela
zero giving up pawns pushing especially
his H pawns forward
um those patterns I think
obviously they were known but uh they
started cropping up in every different
opening due to the influence of alpha
zero and uh yeah I know the players they
were fighting to get kind of get hold of
alpha zero to kind of play training
games against it to get hold of its uh
it's kind of mechanism there so Magnus
was one of the first players who
actually studied Alpha Zero's games and
2019 was like Magnus best year on the on
the chessboard he like won 50 allo
points he was like crushing every
tournament
and he said one of the reasons was as
David pointed out because of uh Alpha
zero he got a lot of new ideas by
studying those games going with the
h-pawn in the openings so technology
plays plays a big role in chess yeah and
yeah I know you guys have told me that
with Alpha zero and artificial
intelligence it's more about
um taking space more than material is
that can you already see that changing
chess
definitely and also Alpha zero Lila
there are these AI engines uh it's
easier to understand for a human in a
way like stockfish sometimes it just
crunches the numbers it's pure
variations and you look at the moves on
their own and they're impossible to
understand you need to look deeper but
somehow when I've looked at uh kind of
Leela zero and when I had the pleasure
of playing against Alpha it just felt
very human in a way it's like the moves
you look at them and they're like oh
actually that's super logical and you
can understand them easier but uh it's
like the circle of life so now we have
ai even stronger than the computers like
stockfish and they're becoming more
human
genius humans then they'll take over
Skynet exactly this is when it's over
all right Magnus now about to tick under
20 minutes on the clock he still has to
make it moves right to reach move 40
where he will gain another hour on the
clock but obviously on a pony actually
he's going to keep the time that he has
right now
the clock situation must be getting to
Magnus right now
one eye on the clock especially if he
chooses to play on should definitely not
go under 10 minutes I think and so it's
like eight moves before move 40 no
increment as well so it's a bit yeah
it's getting a bit risky is that a if if
I mean if Magnus takes under say 15 10
minutes
actually start imposing some problems
just looking at the clocks the good
thing is that he he can always actually
take the draw even if he has like two
minutes left yarn cannot really play on
we can actually show what happens if Jan
decides to play on so white gives a
check with a knight to E8 yeah let's say
he gets gets really low on time and Jan
decides to play King two
h8
okay he played the check I think we're
about to see a draw but if Jan does run
away from the draw Knight C7 I think is
a good move and then threatening the
rook and the pawn F7 so that would not
be a good idea for moves we just win a
pawn for free that's why the King has to
stay on the Square guarding the pawn
and uh now white would just win a very
important Pawn actually and the game so
that's why we're expecting to see a draw
Magnus has given this check the black
king has mentioned has to protect this
pawn and three times right uh what if
Magnus drops yeah that'll be the third
time one time so one more time and you
have to claim correctly as well
yes you have to uh stop the clock and
write down the move and then you have to
call the Arbiter over and you say hey I
am going to make this move and then we
would have repeated the position three
times you can't just make the move if
you make the move and then claim
technically your opponent doesn't have
to make the draw you can play on but
normally the players agree just three
times
he is making his move okay so moment of
truth if Magnus Retreats his Knights
we're about to see a draw and there we
have it yeah so Napoleon actually he has
to move his King forward that's strictly
the only move there we go he stops the
clock as if I can mentioned he doesn't
make the move on the board he stops it
and he tells the other it's about to be
three times then and there we have the
handshake game four End by between these
two is another draw they are still tied
Magnus Carlsen and Jana ponyachi Magnus
on his birthday with the white pieces
this was not what he was hoping for
today definitely not uh far from a
success for the world champion he walked
his opening preparation and literally
actually never had any
say yeah
d6965 I mean
six
7.95 yeah
yeah okay true I'm even here already it
promotes
so yeah attention
V6 36 should be six in your V6 at some
point it should be okay maybe I can yeah
but they also had an interesting move
like 96 and 67 38 and H6 and some parts
not so easy I mean maybe that's just a
necessary session just straight away I
mean you can also take on this island
yeah
I mean maybe you can keep me at all I
wasn't sure
they did discuss the game actually
seemed confident in that discussion I
have to say yeah he's been setting his
dominance actually in some of these
post-game discussions
clearly seeing a lot seeing a lot of
variations and he's not afraid to let
Magnus knows that uh yeah our annoying
Magnus do you think he's frustrated and
not happy with this game right now yeah
for sure frustrated I mean he's the best
player in the world and with white not
being able to pose any problems uh he's
doesn't feel great
talking about the arm being confident
he's uh he's always always been like
that he has a very like high
confidence and always believes in
himself often he under overestimates his
position even so he's always been a
confident guy yeah do you think you
might cut that team leppo is giving high
fives right now another opening with the
black pieces we're doing great yeah with
the black pieces they're doing great
absolutely I mean definitely more so
than game two which was a real roller
coaster of emotions here Magnus stumbled
into preparation and Jan had a very
comfortable draw this is what you want
in match play you want to hold the game
with the black pieces and you want to
strike with white yeah so how did we do
on the predictions today then David none
of us did very well
because I think we all guessed the wrong
opening uh I guess the wrong result at
least
and you got quite close with the moves I
get a few points not too many
unfortunately I guess it was going to be
a draw that was about it okay so your
anchor is going to gain some points here
on our prediction Challenge and you guys
of course also can play the prediction
Challenge on magnusneppo.com game five
will be tomorrow
will have the black pieces I mean uh we
are waiting for interviews with the
players but already looking forward to
that and yawn probably feeling a little
confident after day what do you think
about him with the white pieces tomorrow
definitely gonna get even more confident
after after today making such an easy
draw with with black tomorrow
I'm curious what he's gonna try against
Magnus uh Marshall yeah
um but uh yeah he's definitely gonna try
to play for a win with with whites
um
all about the opening preparation I
think if it gets if he gets a good
position from the opening he can put
some he hopes to put some pressure yeah
we're gonna head to Dubai and the
interview with Magnus Carlsen
barely ever played the Petrov did that
take you by surprise oh you played it in
candidates so I was
um one of the main openings to prepare
for all right but then in this line at
which moment do you think Jan would be
caught off guard or any moment that
would pose a big challenge to him
um yeah this um bc3 instead of Queen B7
is a little bit rare
um
and yeah this whole plan is
it's pretty dangerous for for him I mean
computer shows
you know series and many lines but
practically it's not so easy
um and yeah I thought what he went for
looked a bit dangerous but I couldn't
couldn't see it so I assume it was just
a drop all right and in the end you were
really trying to keep the game going uh
but it looked like you were even though
the result was a peaceful one it looked
like you were frustrated with it uh what
was your mindset in the end no I
wouldn't say I was frustrated I was just
trying so and I didn't didn't find it
and it seemed uh pretty normal all right
thank you
all right Magnus Carlson saying he's not
frustrated but there was no smile on his
face even if it is his birthday David
what is he talking about in the
interview with Tanya here he's talking
about a few things he was talking about
the opening that there were some rare
moves involved there that he was caught
a bit by surprise he'd clearly looked at
this but he didn't expect it necessarily
from napomniacci and it all fizzled out
very quickly and maybe we should just
show a couple of moments and uh maybe in
hindsight Magnus will regret uh forcing
the issue by bringing his Bishop out
this led to a series of uh kind of
simple moves for Napoleon actually to
find we saw the Bishops disappear from
the board we saw pawns disappear as well
and it was around this point that
actually in the discussion between Jan
and Magnus they were just having a chat
about what could happen and I was trying
to eavesdrop trying to follow some of
the variations it was quite complicated
there but after a check here I think
they were just discussing white throwing
this Pawn forward very very quickly and
we mentioned this as well it wasn't too
convincing but maybe it was the best bet
in terms of trying to create winning
chances here Magnus soon installed a
pawn forward but maybe he could have
pressed for uh with the central passport
and caused more problems either way he
mentioned it the computers probably just
says 0.0 probably says a draw from a
human point of view he would have hoped
to put on more pressure with this guy
running but in the end he just couldn't
find anything it was just frustrating
day for the world champion all right
game four a draw between and Magnus
Carlson we are waiting for the press
conference to also hear from yeah before
that we're gonna have a quick commercial
break
foreign
[Music]
the making of a new world starting
October 1st
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
playing experience play in light mode or
dark mode choose from a range of time
controls or create a custom game and get
paired with players from around the
world fast enjoy a polished playing
experience while making moves on a fresh
responsive board to claim your victories
train and improve with over 80 000
puzzles and that's not all download now
and discover what more you can enjoy in
our brand new app
this is John John loves to study chess
[Music]
this is David David loves to study chess
as well but efficiently
John spends more time setting up the
board and figuring out what's on the
page of his book then he gets to study
David likes to take it easy
and use his time wisely
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as a kid I spent hours every day reading
about Chess about openings chess history
and games played between world champions
Grand Masters all of them my apps make
learning much easier everything I know
you can find in my apps Magnus trainer
tactics frenzy and play mindless
you can learn the basic rules of Chess
trained with our 400 lessons and even
play against my digital self
download and try my apps for free
[Applause]
welcome back to chess 24 Global
broadcast we are waiting for the press
conference after game four ended in the
draw we've been very happy to have uh
Grandmaster orientare in the studio
today are an already surprised it was
such a quick day mine was with the white
pieces and everything yeah it shouldn't
come to the studio more
we have to have here for a longer day
yeah
um yeah it was was pity of course that
it ended so so quickly but these games
as I said before
when you when you have 14 games you will
always see some games and ends like this
uh the black player being so well
prepared and uh yeah you just couldn't
do anything yeah what you expect
tomorrow then David when Jan will have
the white pieces and Magnus have been so
well prepared with the black pieces I'm
not sure what I expect but I know what I
want I want Yan to not push his
Kingsport and I want him to try
something different maybe a queen's Pawn
opening maybe an English opening and
just to keep more peace on the board
keep more tension just a bit like Less
Direct because today but also maybe game
three in a way they did fizzle out at
some point with lots of exchanges lots
of Trades and both players just
neutralizing each other there so I'm
hoping Gan maybe tries a different
strategy and puts extra pressure or a
different type of pressure on Magnus
Carlsen all right we're gonna head back
down to Dubai to Tanya and I think Tanya
you're joined by a few more of magnus's
friends that is actually taking the trip
down to Dubai
Kaya it is a wrap for game four and even
though it's Magnus carlsen's birthday
janapamyachi had no gift to give him
whatsoever I think this was another
impressive game by the black pieces Yan
showing how extremely well prepared he
is Magnus in his post game did mention
that he wasn't completely surprised with
the night off uh sorry with the with the
Petrov because I think night off is the
kind of opening that we could expect
but in the end Jan showing that with the
black pieces he still got it under
control and what a surprise or not I
think Magnus was definitely not
expecting this Knight H4 was an
interesting idea at some point but once
again Jan took his time paused did not
rush and managed to keep things under
control in the end we saw the world
champion really trying to push for
something there trying to come up with
some great ideas but that position was
just too late and there was little to be
done in the end the game ended in a draw
I'm not sure what magnus's mindset is
currently for his birthday and I think
I've got the people that we can find out
from we've got two of his friends who've
come to support him who are down here in
Dubai to support Magnus and arnish what
do you think how is Magnus feeling after
this game yeah it's it's still another
Drive we're hoping I was hoping for a
win this time on his birthday and all
but yeah it's still an equal it's not
it's quite normal as well that this this
match starts with a lot of draws so
we'll see what's what happens next all
right
yeah uh uh and yeah I'm not sure what
his plans are for for later there's a
game tomorrow as well so yeah hopefully
Magnus can get away soon
do you think it's going to be a late
night or do you think he's gonna
definitely get some sleep and focus on
tomorrow it's not going to be late uh
uh what we're going to do it depends on
his mood like
like oh so I guess but yeah we'll see
he has to decide what we're going to do
so
we noticed that the football game there
were a lot of
friends there
the rest day and you were playing there
yourself uh how is that is that is that
something that's quite useful for Magnus
during the matches to get some rest by
playing sport yeah during the three days
he likes to play sports like basketball
and football and yeah maybe watch some
football as well so I think it's uh it's
good from to focus on something else in
chess on this free dice when I can yeah
now you guys play some chess yourself
what do you think do you think that
Magnus was expecting the Petrov is that
something that took him by surprise
today
it's probably he can play any line like
but like it's extreme details but I
don't know how much but he knows so much
Theory and these guys are really good
and well prepared so then it's really
hard to win the game
super hard to break through somewhere
now Magnus and Jan have known each other
for such a long time and are good
friends as well is that a dynamic in the
world championship match because it kind
of is what makes it different from the
previous matches yeah perhaps and like
the number shows that this is probably
the most accurate world championship
match that that has ever been played
like the games are almost perfect so
yeah maybe they know each other too too
well so yeah and what's the atmosphere
like once the game is over and Magnus
goes back uh is there a lot of
discussion around the game or is it just
okay let's take a break from all the
chess
I don't know but I think he has a long
talk with Peter Heine and they talk like
not maybe like into depths but like what
could we have done different like you
don't have to focus on the details just
what focus on the next game and just
because what's happened you can't
actually change so I think you just have
to look forward
how long are you guys going to be here
in Dubai supporting Magnus we're only
staying here until Friday so we're
getting two days and tomorrow's game so
we're hoping for some exciting game
tomorrow awesome we look forward to
seeing you guys tomorrow thank you so
much
and there we have magnus's friends uh
down in Dubai supporting the world
champion it is his birthday uh tomorrow
looking forward to a big game five
Magnus takes on with the black manga
starts with the black pieces we'll see
this time what she does with white all
right thanks so much for all your input
from the Dubai today as well Tanya and
two good friends of Magnus is it a good
idea for him today David to celebrate
his birthday maybe with some friends for
sure he needs those Good Vibes and it's
worked for him in the past right Magnus
uh I know when he was in London for the
world championship in 2018 he brought a
lot of friends there as well and it
helped him just maintain his calmness
and stay in the zone and kind of stay in
a good mood yeah for the games yeah do
you expect Magnus not to bring his
friends maybe to his hotel or a
restaurant and actually celebrate
yeah uh usually when I play a tournament
I prepare in the mornings so same day
same day as the as the game so I don't
think Magnus is going to like prepare
too much tonight probably just relax
meet his friends eat some eat some
dinner yeah because obviously a game
start in Dubai is uh 4 30 in you know
midday is that a basically a perfect
game start for chess players that's
perfect I always play my best you know
if I start at 7 p.m or 8pm where you
have it for me and David it's perfect
you prefer the early morning games yeah
early mornings all the way 9 00 a.m I
want it very much the exception though
Ivanka those chess players and night
owls yeah well you said that was a big
success factor for you in in the grand
Swiss that you you never prepared for
your games in the evenings you always
did in the morning yeah actually I was
trying to avoid finding out my opponent
for the next day uh as long as possible
obviously Magnus can't do that however
he knows who he's playing every day so
obviously it might affect his sleep
slightly but yeah for me I prefer not
knowing and just kind of focusing at the
game and working as hard as possible at
the board yeah and you said you do the
same basically Ariana you you prepare in
the morning always yeah I prepared in
the morning uh just like you usually
let's say the game starts at four or
five you finish the game at maybe nine
then you're tired and you want to relax
so just just easier to prepare in the
morning you always have some hours yeah
and from all over
for the press conference
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
loving the little chest cat in the end
is going to make Simon Williams Happy on
his birthday as well he has his own
chess cat at home Charlie did the
Charlie the chess cat I think is uh the
Twitter handle for for Simon's Cat and
we are still waiting for the press
conference to start very very shortly
remember now if you want to analyze
today's game and look at it you can head
over to chessable hanseniman Grandmaster
American Grandmaster is making a course
every day on today's game from the world
championship match so check it out on
the link below all right let's see if
some people are arriving at the press
conference we're wondering the mood
especially if Magnus Carlsen is he a
little bit frustrated with Jana
pulmonachi just
it is not able to surprise him at all
with the white pieces so far David yeah
I think on Magnus Carlson's part it will
be quite a somber mood
um he'll have a lot to think about a lot
of questions to answer tonight and
before the next game and there we see
the players arriving yeah and the point
actually with his mask Magnus looking
relaxed but uh we'll see the mood
all right let's head to the press
conference led by Grandmaster Maurice
questions can be asked at the
microphones to the size of the room
please do not touch the microphones and
always at all times wear your mask as
you ask questions and please direct your
questions to the individual player or
players but if you want both to answer
name the one you would like to answer
first
uh Magnus at first I will let me say
happy birthday
and we in that regard what if you may
let us know is your history of playing
chess on your birthday and how did that
possibly affect your approach today or
your mindset today in today's game
um I would have of course loved to have
a rest day uh on the eve of my my
birthday so that I could like have a at
least a token celebration
um apart from that I would say it's
pretty good I think I won at least one
game in the World Cup
um against almond I believe in 2005 and
obviously the match in 2016 was decided
on my on my birthday in the in the tie
break so it's gonna take a lot to for me
to have bad Recollections of me playing
on my birthday even though I lost uh
lost to uh to uh so last year
uh Jan did this matter to you at all
that it was magnus's birthday the chess
players have superstitions uh your
experience on your birthday and how that
might have affected today yeah
absolutely I uh okay Mama my big goal
was not to forget to congratulate Magnus
yeah
uh I mean at least after the game yeah
so once again congratulations
uh but uh as for me I think it was very
different so I I believe
in childhood I played a few games uh on
my birthday but it was
I mean it it never was easy or something
yes so in general
I think
trying to recall this in the memory it
was like like some another game and
yeah normally turn on the effects of
that you are basically having no party
because uh because uh yeah you know
you're going to play the next day or
something yeah
Magnus uh this is your second white
today your expectation about the Petrov
it's not traditional opening that yarn
plays were you surprised at all by it
uh no it was one of the main openings
that I've expected seeing that he played
it in the in the in the candidates and
also
um in the first black game he um went
for uh for a more classical classical
approach rather than than a sharp one so
it was very much uh much expected
um couldn't know obviously which
exact petroflani was gonna he was gonna
go for but um Petrov in itself was very
much expected and your feeling about the
opening you got
well I'm what can I say I tried
something concrete uh and um it didn't
work uh but that's I think
uh normal normal results
um
I didn't expect him obviously to have
to have missed the line that I played
um uh completely but yeah in some other
iterations there can be a lot of
um difficult decisions to to make for
for black but I think yeah the way that
he he played
um there was just there are some
different tries but there's just nothing
and
set of state of modern chess not much
else to say you did though at the end
look like you were working like overtime
sweating to try to get something at the
end they look you look like you were
really trying very hard before you
finally stopped
uh why was that
um I I think
um
it sometimes happens uh at World
Championships that you work you work a
lot uh before the before the match and
you work a lot during the match and
openings and such
um and somehow this makes you work less
over the board my Approach was very
clear there that I didn't think
particularly that I had had anything but
I I have two hours for the game so I
should spend them all uh looking for
whatever chances can can be found
yeah and did you feel like you were in
any difficulty at any point during this
game
well the actually the language which
happened is I guess uh should be known
by many who who play petrol yes so it's
one of the lines which are quite
principle
uh despite this I believe Knight is 4 is
very interesting try but uh perhaps I
even wanted to play this as white one
day yeah well uh but in general yeah the
task was more or less about not to mix
up things yeah and not to I don't know
not to do something stupid because uh as
far as I know this line is more or less
to say so safe for black so of course I
was checking twice everything and also
calculating a lot but in general yeah I
think this is quite safe
draw for this game satisfying result
well since I played Petrov indeed
and for you Magnus uh second White
took a shot but again a draw is this at
all frustrating or is still early in the
match no it's okay
um I've started with
a lot more draws than this earlier
um and um
when you play when you play a forest
line as
as today
um
you
um you don't expect to
uh to hit very very often but the idea
is to
um to hit once in a while take your
opponent by surprise and the other times
you're you're usually going to be very
safe
um so
um
yeah I I
would have would have loved to to win uh
would have loved to find more chances
than I I did but I think overall that's
uh it's a normal result against the well
prepared opponents
we'll take our first question from
reporters in the room please well I'm
wounded from the chess24 global
broadcast and of course the entire chess
2014 wishes you a happy birthday and
Magnus our question is for you uh I'm
sure that chess fans all over the world
hopes for you how that you can go out
and celebrate and have a very nice
birthday will this be possible for you
or do you have to just work work in
order to prepare for tomorrow
um yeah I'm playing playing tomorrow
um I feel like general idea of world
championship match is that you celebrate
after you've hopefully won that makes a
lot of sense
yeah micro uh Sagar Shah from chessvis
India my question is to Magnus first of
all happy birthday
all right the press conference going on
I think uh minus maybe a better mood
than we suspected yep I think he's just
being realistic that's that's all plenty
of games left
um okay it hasn't been going according
to plan quite but it hasn't necessarily
been a disaster either so
um yeah now he's just gonna relax
tonight I think and try and save some
energy for a really really important
game tomorrow yeah Aryan are you gonna
follow the games from Norway are you
traveling to Dubai what's your plans
going forwards I'm actually going to
Canada on on Monday uh that's that's
just the whole day visiting my friends
Eric Hansen and Aman Hamilton wow so we
all know those two uh chess bro of
course uh very famous streamers yeah and
very but they are uh if you watch chess
they are pretty popular yeah super
popular so basically if people wanna
watch you in the future they can check
out chess bra on Twitter yeah definitely
going to be on their streams yeah all
right
will you guys be following the match and
and maybe uh you know
analyze them a little bit yeah for sure
we're definitely gonna watch I mean the
world championship is such a
big thing like it's every second there
now it's actually every uh it was three
years ago last time so the whole Chess
World just always looks forward to it
and watches with great interests cool
and you've been guest starring on a lot
of streams lately now with the chess
bars last week with the boater systems
is this uh the start of ah a new career
possible
we'll see it's uh it's nice to make some
appearances uh here and there yeah uh
it's fun I've I have my own channel on
Twitch but I haven't been streaming so
much once in a while is it is it hard if
you're going to be a top top player you
know in the top hundreds
to be able to do that at the same time
as playing is it basically impossible
because it's just two jobs yeah it's I
think it's hard to combine so mostly
I've been just focusing on my own career
but uh yeah just one once in a while but
not not too often because it's
especially if you have many events it's
uh it's hard to like stream every day
yeah like Magnus Carlsen the occasional
hot tub streaming you're welcome to join
us looking forward all right well our
antari he's traveling to Canada uh we're
gonna take a look at the schedule that
we have every day that there is a game
going on so we start every day at one
o'clock CET that is seven in the morning
in the US and New York it's uh four
o'clock in Dubai and game five is coming
up tomorrow there's gonna be a rest day
the day after that
but uh next game Magnus Carlsen black
pieces white pieces game five tomorrow
will we finally have a decided games 18
games in a row in the world championship
matches has now ended with a draw in the
classical games for Magnus Carlsen maybe
tomorrow we'll have a win hope you guys
will join us again thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign